you know to be completely honest uh what
is this someone so Luke's already
playing audio all right to be completely
honest I don't like being the subject of
the news story as much as people try to
claim that they're like oh he was trying
to get attention or whatever you know we
wanted to have we had an opportunity we
thought we were lucky to have several
people on the show who were in the news
because even right now Mitch McConnell's
coming out you've got uh Piers Morgan
coming out stories about Donald Trump
refusing to denounce Nick Fuentes
because he doesn't want to alienate
voters this is the dominant story it's
unfortunate we weren't able to actually
talk about the news but we have a lot of
details to go through stuff I talked
about in the morning new details that
have emerged now that they had a private
plane ready for them after they left the
show which it's entirely possible they
were able to to get a private plane very
very very quickly but it also seems very
very rare and unlikely but again I'm not
I don't want to accuse him of anything I
think it's possible that they had this
planned they've been adamant they didn't
plan this and I think it worked out very
well for somebody who want to revenge on
Trump considering the news cycle so
we'll talk about that plus what's been
going on outside of that and of course
we want to talk about censorship and
Elon Musk before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work we will have a members
only uncensored show for you tonight we
didn't have one yesterday because you
know we had yeah on and he left and uh
I'll say it again dude doesn't owe me
anything if he wants to leave so be it
nobody has to stick around in the show
they can always bail on me that's the
way it goes dudes a powerful billionaire
or former billionaire what do you want
to call them the last thing you need to
sit here and and have me talk about
whatever so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us to
apologize is our good friend I'll just
throw it to you
Tim I'm sorry I left the show yesterday
it was a complete apology and I was very
wrong and I'll be back whenever you like
vote for me in 2024. okay how was that I
was okay I guess well I didn't want to
be too you know edgy no because then I
wouldn't want to steal rolls from black
actors oh yeah yeah I don't want to get
in the holy poo situation oh right right
so you're Michael mallick I am Michael
malice yes shalom I'm here representing
Zog okay
what do you do thanks for coming man I
think most people know who you are oh
okay
what's your biggest claim your face I am
the organizer the anarchist handbook you
guys can get the hardcovers at Anarchist
handbook.bigcartel.com and I was on a
billboard because of you guys that's
right in Times Square and my next book
oh this is the big news before we get
into this stuff I finished my next book
the white pill
yesterday I'm uploading it to Amazon
Thursday I think and we're gonna launch
it live on timcast and see if we can get
a book to number one on Amazon live and
make internet history very cool you're
self-publishing yeah that's awesome why
go through uh make Michael malice uh uh
the number one Amazon I hit number three
this hit number three uh so hopefully we
can hit number one very cool man uh well
how do you describe yourself for those
who aren't familiar with you I am uh an
anarchist without adjectives I have a
podcast called you're welcome Twitter
douche
um and love lover of All Peoples well
okay
right on we got Luke hanging out I think
I'm I'm supposed to say shalom Assam
alaikum right I think that's that's what
I'm supposed to say there hi there my
name is Luke kardowski here of we are
change.org and today I have a t-shirt of
uh Schwab I thought I was supposed to be
the Jewish one
of Klaus Schwab saying that you will get
no presents and you will be happy which
you could exclusively get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
guys do that that's one of the main
reasons why I am here thank you again so
much for supporting me the best
politicalshirts.com Ian I I'm sorry
you're perturbed your crystals have been
Disturbed I told Nick I told Nick I was
like hey man they have LSD on them and
then and then he was like joking and
then like five minutes he was like Hey
really did it I was like yeah
but then Milo came down and he just like
not got high on LSD Milo you like LSD
Milo uh no I think your brain is broken
I like those guys that was a chaotic
situation last night I hope that we get
a chance to talk to them in the future
and kind of figure out you know like I
was saying last night they're like Ian
would you have them back on and I'm like
yeah I'm the kind of guy where they're
like why would you interview the devil
Crossland and I'm like because people
keep saying he's evil I want to know why
no he's also good Devil's gonna be
pretty careful yeah let's talk about
this this is actually a good thing to
get into like hosting them what people
were saying your thoughts and everything
so we'll get into it and before we do I
want to point out yes you're welcome
Michael malice show uh I don't know
YouTube and do you run it through any
portals on whip your website or anything
at this point no just it's on YouTube I
was on Spotify it's on uh it's on uh
Rumble it's on Odyssey I was on an
episode if you guys haven't seen me it
was excellent Michael's a great
interview it was a lot of fun very fun
and I haven't seen you since then so
that's true good to see you buddy you
look good thank you we got storage
hanging out hey low energy Serge Dupree
what's up everybody how you doing
YouTube take it away to him let's let's
talk about worse by far is surge very
weak very low energy I do want to
mention one quick thing too I had a
phone call with Google today there are
panicking over section 230 reform so the
Supreme Court has agreed to take up a
case pertaining to recommendations and
so YouTube is now actively lobbying
prominent creators I suppose I got an
email and it asked me to sign up for a
certain date to talk to their head of
policies very nice but uh I was uh uh
personally offended at the things that
he was saying so I'm not trying to be
mean to the guy we're going to talk
again probably tomorrow but uh it seemed
like they were trying to Lobby me to
agree that YouTube should have the right
to be politically biased and be immune
from defamation which I absolutely do
not so we'll talk about that too but we
got to get into this stuff so here's the
first story yeah many of you may have
seen what happened last night on this
show and
um I have concerns that we had yay
Fuentes and Milo on the show a lot of
people messaged me beforehand saying why
are you having them on what they're
using you they have an agenda and I'm
and who's they who's they no no but
listen listen they say they say uh they
as in general people messaging me
they're using you Tim they're using you
and I said for all of them why do you
think people come on this show do you
think they're coming on because they
love me and they want to hold my hand
and smile and look at my face or do you
think they're trying to promote a book
do you think they're trying to get a
message out they're trying to promote
their Twitter accounts they have ideas
they want to share of course everyone's
using everybody I have guests on so we
can make an interesting show it's our
business they come on because it's an
opportunity for them to to share or sell
or whatever I thought we were friends I
think again that's that's my we're only
having you on because you make us laugh
okay I guess I'm a clown
[Laughter]
so here's here's what I want to say
because um right now there's a lot of
stories you know uh Trump is being told
that he's got to denounce these guys
there was a story that popped up on Fox
Fox 5 Kanye West spotted in Frederick
after storming off of podcast
here's the potential scenario to be fair
the scenario is they abruptly left the
show they were on it yay didn't like
that I was not agreeing with him or that
I was pushing back in any capacity got
up and stormed off Milo and Nick working
for yay wouldn't stick around and left
immediately they called a charter
company to schedule a private plane who
was very very they were very lucky that
a hot crew it's what they're on the
ground ready to go was available nearby
and was able to then dispatch a plane to
Frederick that they could then get into
within a couple hours notice entirely
possible my personal opinion
that sounds really really crazy if
that's the case so when I when when they
stormed off the show my my first thought
was that
um like okay you started off the show
then we talked about it and I said it
was the perfect thing to do if you want
to generate press there's a story going
around that Donald Trump met with Nick
Fuentes and anti-sema anti-semite white
supremacist that was all last week first
day first thing this week we have this
show and I think it was the first thing
Nick said on the show was that something
about it isn't it really them and then
immediately yay gets up and walks out
downstairs smile on his face eating
cookies apparently uh one of our one of
our guys here said that when they were
leaving he said something like I came to
the show got what I needed now I'm done
I'm leaving and so that made me wonder
about what was the goal it's possible
maybe I'm just thinking too much into it
that Milo wanted revenge on Trump Milo
was quoted as saying he invited Nick
because he knew Trump would mishandle it
in the Press he wanted to make Trump's
life Trump's life miserable Trump is
mishandling in the press the first thing
thing out of uh I believe it was the
first thing out of out of Nick's mouth
was but isn't it them and then yay
leaves right around the half an hour
mark when we're at a hundred thousand
concurrent viewers and that said to me
they had to have planned this then I saw
the video of them going to the Frederick
airport boarding a what appears to be a
super mid private jet right after the
show within a few hours and I was like
how did they Charter a private jet that
fast
it is entirely possible they did I know
where the jet originated we did some
sleuthing to figure it out what happened
was about a half an hour's flight time
away a hot crew uh this is what I'm told
it is entirely possible these are by the
experts in the in the private Aviation a
hot crew was available it was or said
I'm sorry what they said was a plane
nearby flew to Frederick
landed for about an hour and then
departed with them it is entirely
possible that they happened upon what's
called a hot crew that's what they said
meaning they were people on the ground
working ready to take off but for no but
for no reason the plane was not being
used yay is very powerful wealthy
individual perhaps he knows somebody and
someone has his back it's interesting
considering everything's been saying
about how they're trying to arrest him
and shut him down and silence him and
censor him but apparently he was able to
get within two hours notice a super mid
private jet to fly from here to Los
Angeles with a crew active
I I I I don't know what happened but to
me it sounds staged it sounded like they
knew in advance they'd be leaving at
least yay may have because that's that's
not the vibe I got I got that they seem
very genuine when they were here I I
know Milo I mean he's a gen I mean he's
he's a zany dude but like he's looking
for Redemption that's his path right now
and Kanye is grasping at straws to try
and find someone to help him and Nick
was so kind the entire time he was here
like I've heard stuff about him I've
seen him say stuff online out of context
that's racist but when you see him eyes
to eyes like the guy is looking for
friends like he doesn't probably has
been lived in an environment where he
didn't have a lot of friends so when you
what happened was you and Kanye were
going back and forth and kind of
interrupting each other you mentioned at
one point Tim you were holding your
finger up before you want to jump in and
he was over the show and he's like you
you want to say something go for it
before the show yeah and even so when
the show started it his demeanor changed
so you guys were kind of had an
agreement like we're gonna kind of talk
over each other we're gonna flow but
then when Nick chimed in and you
interrupted Nick Kanye's face dropped
and then he got out he was like that's
you crossed the line when you throw up
me that's okay you were up Nick I'm out
before the show when we're doing
pre-show and setting up it was so
different
Kanye said yay I'm sorry said few things
I pushed back and he just had a smile on
his face and he's like nodding along
like whatever the show comes on
and all of a sudden he's like we went to
Trump stand I was invited first I called
Milo so anyway let's talk about
anti-Semitism and I'm like whoa like we
were just talking before the show you
know what happened the first article no
he knew what the article was we had the
article pulled up pre-show he mentioned
Pence he asked Fuentes about Pence and
what Trump I said is that we'll we'll
use this story to launch the dinner and
the controversy caused by it and I'll
ask you about how this dinner came to be
what do you think about it what happened
with it and then what is yay 24 and I
was like who am I kidding we're gonna
get into the anti-Semitism stuff I'm
gonna push back here's how it'll play
out like I'm gonna if you guys want to
say something I'm gonna put my hand up
and let you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
talk about this and they're like of
course no problem absolutely fine and
then as soon as the show started all of
a sudden it was like oh how dare you
bring up this article oh my here's what
I don't understand about that dinner
that doesn't make sense to me you do not
get a plus three to meet with the
president I don't care who you are that
it's not Piers Morgan had a piece today
that he you know he won The Apprentice
he was I think the first winner of the
Celebrity Apprentice he was interviewing
Trump at Mar-A-Lago the Secret Service
you know basically gives you an anal
swab before we're going to meet a former
president especially if we're dealing at
Mar-A-Lago which not that long ago was
rated because there were concerns about
things that are classified whatever top
secret so on and so forth I don't
understand how if you're running for
president and this is the scenario in
your home you're going to have dinner
with someone anyone and be like oh yeah
you know bring bring your buddies and
not be paranoid even just for security
reasons who are these people are they
spies are they so on and so forth I
don't understand that we we struggle
with this
here when we're when we're bringing
people in
we have to be we have sent this big
long-winded email about who's allowed
here what this means yeah vetted by you
stuff like that now I wouldn't say it's
like we're that strict where we but
you're not the president exactly you're
not a former president it's absolutely
Beggars believe and the other thing is
like Jake wieger had a tweet about like
this isn't a surprise this is who Trump
hangs out with white supremacists it's
like when someone's the president you
know exactly what they're hanging out
with you know every minute of their day
whether they're having for dinner and so
on and so forth It's not a big secret
their their schedule is very public and
very known and it's it's a very big deal
this is the president of the United
States in this case the foreign
president United States so what Trump is
saying does not uh cut ice with me and
what else is crazier to me in all
seriousness his daughter converted to
Judaism right so this is something that
obviously and I think one of his other
kids married a Jewish woman so he the
joke is like what's the difference
between a New York Times reader and
Donald Trump Donald Trump's
grandchildren are going to be Jewish
it's like if he has this in his family
for him to be like well oops I didn't
know so that's just confusing
you think he just trusted Kanye and was
like if you want to bring whoever but
why would you trust but he just tried I
think first of all he has this this
boner for celebrities that is really
demented because that explains why he's
endorsing Dr Oz who believe Justice
Millet who was for Trans kids surgeries
you know who had the whole laundry list
of like you know very Lefty ideas
Herschel Walker who's just a football
star uh for Senate like in the The Love
Affair Donald Trump has for people who
are blue checks is demented I want to I
think Ian's right about one thing that
this guy's looking for friends
I can't speak to the things that I any
of them have said in the past like what
I should say is like obviously they've
said deplorable things testable things
but what I genuinely believe is
we had Milo on this show a couple weeks
ago and he talked about supporting Trump
he talked about vengeance he wasn't
talking about this stuff it was it was
his Focus was different then he gets
involved with with yay brings in Fuentes
and all of a sudden this is like a
particular component of his his career
or his personality what I think happens
is when you cancel people they go in the
only Direction they can wait I I can
disagree because I have receipts from
Milo because when this all came out I
wrote a book about this there's a
chapter up Milo in my book and then you
write I think Milo is very very Charming
he's very very witty he's certainly very
intelligent and of all the people who
got canceled the reason he got canceled
I think was one of the more BS reasons
uh he was the victim of childhood abuse
he spoke out about in a kind of
tongue-in-cheek manner I don't begrudge
anyone who's suffered through something
like that how they should deal with the
situation and he was basically saying
things like okay you know this is
something that I'm he's kind of
rationalizing like I'm glad this
happened to me at a young age as opposed
to being like holy crap you know I got
my innocence taken up taken from me at a
time when it shouldn't have so I think
the fact that that key was just like you
know get out like everything's ruined
for you because of something that had
been done to him where he was innocent
as a kid or teenager I thought was
really kind of over the top and clearly
it was like Al Capone going to jail
because of income taxes it really wasn't
income tax there's looking for an excuse
to get rid of him but he did an article
um a couple years ago with the Jewish
Journal because when this all came out
I'm like I thought Milo was Jewish
because I remember this being a thing at
the time when he pushed back about the
Nazis about this I sent the hold on let
me pull it up I got the uh DM here and
here's the article from the Jewish
Journal this is from 2019 uh and he was
talking about this then because this is
with the Jewish journal and he had said
I'm quoting Milo here
um let me get out he goes he thinks the
Jewish Community the Jewish Lobby would
be well served to not throw a gas gasket
every time someone throws out what it
may appear to be an anti-semitic Trope
and he says this is quoting Milo just
like I don't like left-wing political
correctness about women in blacks and
Muslims I don't like right-wing
political correctness about Jews in
Israel so and he said people claim that
really stupid things are anti-Semitic
that are not really anti-semitic where
they make more of a fuss about it than
they need to so at a certain point he
has been addressing this at least 2019
so three years ago what I mean to say is
uh if these guys were given an
opportunity if if some if some obviously
it would never happen but if you went to
any one of these guys and said we want
you to be a brand ambassador for a big
company to make you a lot of money but
you got to stay away from these subjects
they'd say yes
yeah probably I think what happens is
when
people get love bombed
you'll get somebody who like starts
getting a bunch of tweets where they're
like hey I like what you're saying keep
saying more of it and then they're going
to start feeling good they're going to
be like Oh I'm getting all this
attention building followers and then
some people are just gonna say like this
these are people supporting me and I'm
gonna side with them but there's an
inverse to that when you ban someone and
they have nowhere to go and they can't
get Redemption they will go to whoever
is willing to accept them and on top of
just the love bombs it's the financial
incentive because if people are getting
paid because they have a following now
they're getting ad revenue or they're
getting direct subscriptions no matter
what they're saying if they're saying
really cruel evil things and they're
getting paid for it
um that's free speech but also that can
incentivize the continuation of the
behavior and it's kind of tough to dig
out especially if you get canceled
you're like well the only people that
pay me are these people and they only
watch me because of this content so
let's do more of that when you get
canceled when you get censored you get
sent off to the Far Corners of the
internet where a lot of people get
radicalized and people need to
understand and bad ideas need to be
fought with good ideas and we don't have
this battle of ideas we never had this
battle of ideas mainly because of
centralized controllers big Tech
intervening and saying no we don't like
what you're saying we don't like your
political stance be gone you're and then
those ideas are never routinely
challenged routinely questioned uh
there's no pushback against them and
only in places where they fester and
grow are are these kind of larger
elements that that again never see the
light of public day and I and I think
this is why when you need to debate we
need to argue we need to of course
create Steelman arguments and a question
and debate everything this is another
takeaway I had from last night I love
the YouTube as a as a platform I've
Loved this in Steve Chen and Chad Hurley
built the thing and the third guy who I
don't know the name of Sergeant uh and
it but last night conversation was not a
conversation for YouTube in its current
state if you guys want to fix up your
terms of service into a more free speech
oriented thing it would be but when we
have people on that there's a chance
they might violate the terms of service
of platform we got to go to another
platform because we need to let those
guys speak those people need to speak
and then let them because if Kanye had
went on for 30 minutes and then Nick
responded for 20 minutes and they said
all sorts of offensive things that
YouTube would have stopped we'd have a
chance to rebut and talk about it and
come to some sort of consensus that
ideally we would all come out of better
people from Michael's got this look on
his face well I I mean I I think the
problem is whenever like let's look at
um like let's say something that's
Radioactive in a different way the
recent ad campaign about Balenciaga
right so if you're going to have people
talking about the pros and cons of
Balenciaga you can send them ads where
they had those kids with the teddy bears
and bondage and I want to use words
carefully I can see how a corporation
would be like you know what we're trying
to have a certain image and have a
certain platform and there's certain
things that are going to be uh Beyond
The Pale here and because they have to
be worrying about their advertising I'm
okay with that power of corporate
America is just absolutely enormous I I
there was another story about Balenciaga
they had done similar ad campaigns and
people are saying there's no way that
that slipped like there's no way they
produce an ad and didn't know what they
were producing I I think there's
absolutely a way because this is how
because I think we all we forget how
dumb suits are so all it would take
would be one uh um art director and then
for him to be like look it's already
it's edgy the kids were not being shown
themselves in any kind of uh provocative
or a state of
um uh undress they were just showing
iconography which is very different from
like Maple Thorpe who's at museums where
you're showing full frontal on little
girls which got funding which oh yeah oh
you didn't know without Maple third
thing this oh this oh this is a this is
another example of how the corporate
press is just completely dishonest if
you look at articles Maple Thorpe had
funding from uh um the art the Nea right
the National Endowment for the Arts and
he was this great photographer a lot of
the photography he was taking was very
very transgressive would be like two men
one has a whip somewhere another one was
the razor on his you know what and he
had and then then Jesse Helms with
Center at the time says this is not
where our money should be going to and
he was condemned as homophobic well many
of these images were literally child
pornography there's one of a little girl
with her knee up flashing her genitals
to the camera but if you read any USA
Today Washington Post article it really
just sounds like you've got two guys
kissing and Jesse Helms the homophobe
has a problem with it so it's completely
skewed and just just let me finish so in
terms of Balenciaga if you look at it
you could be like oh it's kids with
teddy bears it's like they're punks you
know you got this badass thing you're
not gonna really read oh here's the
printout of this lawsuit here's what
this book entails so on and so forth I
disagree I don't think it suits missing
it I think the the messaging was clear
there's a history of it and I think
there's a reason Balenciaga deleted
their Instagram deleted their Twitter
because people were picking up on more
and more and more signs there's no way
that you could see that image and be
like yeah totally fine totally okay
there's no way it was so blatant it was
so in our face and there was multiple
instances multiple uh multiple times
where it's just extremely Troublesome
and for an executive to look at it and
say oh Teddy Bears BDSM dolls yeah yeah
babies laying down in in precarious ways
oh yeah the tape here or this case
there's no way they missed it I think it
was a deliberate sign to just brag about
what they were doing when you look at
when you look at the Fashion industry
they have a long history of being uh let
me just finish really quickly they have
a long history of of having a lot of
Jeffrey Epstein types Jeffrey Epstein
was all in the fashion industry and a
lot of the other individuals that were
on that Client List are still in the
fashion industry who were never held
responsible for their crimes and whether
it's running Victoria's Secret sending
out this messaging this messaging is not
something that is an accident because
they've been doing it for many years
trying to normalize children as models
and a lot of the female models look like
young boys I don't think that's an
accident I think a lot of this is on
purpose because there's a lot of very
dark Sinister people in that industry
that wanted to gloat and highlight how
bad they are and they want to get away
with it and this was this rep
presentation from what I saw I've not
disagreeing with anything you said what
I'm saying is it's not that they missed
it it's that the suit was like this
isn't my job uh you have a photographer
that photographer has a brand name I'm
just the guy the money guy I'm gonna let
him do what he wants it's not my place
to jump and interject and basically in
that industry these people who have
brand names like Balenciaga is a brand
name can basically have free reign to do
whatever the heck they want they spend
millions of dollars on these fashion
shoots and it works for them for every
little detail I mean the president of
the United States literally decides what
kind of tie he wants to to set a
particular mood to have the particular
background there's no way they're
spending millions of dollars on these
fashion shoots and not micromanaging
every little small animal you're not
hearing what I'm saying what I'm saying
is I don't think it's a suit I think it
was deliberately done and I think of the
students were complicit in it okay I I
think a lot of times in big corporations
the responsibility is very much
disjointed and one hand is not knowing
what the other hand is doing and I think
the reason wait hold on the reason why
this social media got pulled is because
then someone realized holy crap
otherwise they would have left it up
because they're like this has been going
on for a long time we got to do an
analysis to figure out when this started
how many of these iterations are there
so you think people were like seeding
this information into the oh they
definitely were it's not even questions
it's it's everywhere in our
entertainment especially if you look at
Disney especially if you look at the
subliminal subconscious mind control
which I particularly call it and the
larger kind of degeneracy that is being
pushed on the individuals and even the
corporate media even talking about Minor
attracted persons there's a huge agenda
when it comes to trying to normalize
this kind of debauchery this kind of
horrible behavior that a lot of powerful
people inside of the government were
committing especially when they were
going to that private island and doing
absolutely horrible things to children
that they kidnapped if you look at the
cover of the DVD for The Little Mermaid
if you look at us at the scene in
Aladdin where they're getting married in
the scene in Aladdin the priest is
excited let me just put it that way if
you look at the background of The Little
Mermaid one of the towers looks like a
certain thing of a male anatomy my point
is a lot of times these artists will put
things that the suit will be oblivious
to that's all and that's one example
where you're wasn't wasn't there a movie
The Great Mouse detected or something
where there was like an actual they put
like like porn somewhere in it or
something like that people people
chatted this there's a bunch of adult
content and wieners all throughout uh
you know content for for small children
and uh I think when it comes to these
particular cases uh we know so little
because a lot of this is done in secrecy
we shouldn't be excusing it as an
accident we should always with the
absence of evidence when we see very
Sinister people who have a history of
hurting small children always think the
worst case possible scenario and demand
more evidence and I think excusing
excusing it as oh the suits just missed
it is is an instant or element I'm sorry
if I if I got your argument wrong but I
don't I'm saying the suits just missed
it I said in very many cases because how
these people work is they will get
things past the goalie because the
people who are looking don't know what
to look for and are oblivious to it and
in fact the fact that this has been
going up
the fact that this has been going on for
so long and has only been picked up now
speaks to the point that I'm making that
they're very good at getting things on a
subliminal level that people aren't
going to register so if you have
Balenciaga ads and you have literally
tens of thousands of people seeing these
ads and they're only getting picked up
now that just speaks to my point that a
lot of times the money guy or the
accountant or whoever is is kind of
signing off on this they're not going to
always be aware of what they're saying
yeah I I I I don't mind being compared
to Ian I think Ian's great uh but but at
the same time never excuse me I know I
never tried to blame something that that
it could be construed as an accident
when it could be malice that's backwards
sorry sorry hold on I'll explain it to
him hanlon's razor is the opposite would
prove malice would would suggest Mouse
is right never a tribute to malice that
which can be explained by incompetence
yes thank you you said that a lot better
than I but that would imply that Mouse's
argument is is more likely true I would
just say one point on this I I agree a
bit with with you Michael
um and and I'm not trying to argue other
I think someone intentionally did this
and intentionally for a long time no
question and there are people who are
supposed to be Gatekeepers right if
hundreds of thousands or millions of AD
viewers
didn't even notice this
it's possible that The Gatekeepers of
these companies don't notice this stuff
either but someone is intentionally
doing it if you look at Hollywood
history like there were a lot of gay
references that were meant there for gay
audiences whereas the straight people
watching this and the executives would
be completely oblivious and there's
College course about this where they go
back and deconstruct these old movies
the higher you go up in a lot of these
bigger institutions especially
corporations the more likelihood that
there's going to be a sociopath in them
yes so so on that assessment and in the
absence of evidence I'm going to assume
the worst mainly because I know what
they're capable of and I think we should
from a point of view not excusing their
behavior but at the same time saying hey
they have a long history here let's get
the evidence here because they they
probably are doing some of the most
awful Sinister horrible things that you
can't even fathom and imagine yourself
you're talking to me who are you
perceiving as excusing this Behavior no
no I'm saying the court the the suits
that just were not aware of it but
that's not an excuse that's an
explanation if you're signing off on
something that allows them but that
gives them a way to say oh we just
didn't know yes absolutely we didn't
know we just didn't see this happening I
don't want to even give them that but I
I think I think where you and I disagree
let's take away from Balenciaga is if
you look at let's suppose the Senate
right or or politicians a lot of these
people in power are not very bright and
a lot of times it's their stabs staffs
that are doing these malevolent things
and are putting things over and the
American people things in terms of War
so I that and that's one of the reasons
why I'm so hopeful is because when you
look at the people who tend to be in
power they're really often very
unimpressive yeah I I think they they
use that as a way to cover their larger
actions you think Biden knows what the
hell is going on um absolutely not he's
a puppet and I think there's there's
bigger controllers and there's other
interests right behind them okay
sorry well it sounds like you guys are
both right it was both malice and
incompetence at some level people were
maliciously putting chocolate 100 malice
I did it zero and Company I did it I got
away with it and I'll do it again so I
this is interesting conversation I used
to call a minor attracted people because
I'm like well I want to be sensitive
about these this this whatever this
delusion or whatever now I'm like okay
pedophile but the thing about pedophile
is there's a big difference between a 20
year old and a 17 year old hooking up
consensually and a 25 year old and a
nine-year-old getting it on but when the
nine-year-old doesn't know what's
happening that's just with all
directions they're both considered
pedophiles no they're not well I mean if
one kid one's a consensual statutory
rape no okay listen Ian there's
something called Romeo and Juliet laws
yes 15 years old or 16 years old
wherever it's not legal and then there's
another word for that I guess I I guess
I don't know whenever you see that word
written on the Internet run away from
the hill exactly you're like it I I get
at that point it's like it doesn't
matter my point is if if two young
people are within three three or four
years of age many states say that's
that's protected depending like I think
in in some of the states they have these
like like 13 is the limit or 14 is the
limit so basically between 14 and 18 are
shielded from these laws or whatever but
it would be within three years of like
20. so if you're like a 20 and a 17 year
so like if a 25 year old and a 17 year
old consensually were hooking up it's
big difference than a 25 year old and a
nine-year-old no one's a little green
with you so but they're both called
pedophiles that's the problem with the
word it's so charged that if someone
gets statutory rape accusation and
they're 25 and she's 17 or they're 23.
17 and 25 is not a pedophile well a lot
of people I think consider them because
they're considered minors they consider
them pedophiles and that's dangerous I
agree that it's dangerous but I think
there's there was a New York Times
article several years ago when they were
looking at I mean this is going to be a
darker episode than I expect well why
don't we why don't we get my friendly
language they were talking about yay
politics yeah let's get to the fun stuff
you know the juice uh there was a New
York Times article they were there
investigating uh child pornography and
according to that piece the whoever the
FBI I guess it was didn't have enough
staff to even handle the infants that
were being in these videos so the amount
of uh um very young uh stuff that's out
there is profoundly disturbing and I was
going to write a book about this I
talked to my agent about it several
years ago and he's like do you really
want to be doing this research and I'm
like yes and there's multiple incidences
of people coming to Big platforms like
Twitter a couple years ago and saying
hey my photos here when I was underage
are being leaked here Twitter's saying
oh yeah yeah we'll do something about it
and then ignoring those people talk
about this screwing them over and then
at the same time now Twitter for the
first time is saying we're going to be
addressing this problem and now the
Apple App Store is going to do is
threatening to cancel them that's
absolutely because this is the one this
is the you got me triggered now okay now
I'm gonna go full Luke Elon Musk uh
Eliza blue if you're out there I think
she's been on the show yeah this has
been her big issue getting a CP off of
Twitter God bless her this is something
that is uh unambiguously a problem
something unambiguously horrific and you
Naval period end of story and a lot of
times people who are in as you said were
in these picked images or videos would
contact Twitter and Twitter shrug their
hands Elon Musk took over and he's like
all right this is going to be like
Priority One like this is a complete
non-starter this has got to go we could
worry about racism homophobia
transphobia gender pronouns whatever
this is a problem Forbes
who is an agent of the devil wrote a
tweet an article that says Elon Musk has
tried to take on uh Twitter's child
abuse nightmare but according to experts
has only made it worse and they tweet it
nine times I looked up how often Forbes
had mentioned Twitter and children in
the past they've literally never even
used those two words together previously
so now that Elon is trying to do
something about it Forbes has an issue
with it because they don't have an issue
with it they have an issue with Elon
Musk so this speaks to what Luke is
saying how many people there are in
power who do not care about children at
all but who only care about power and
who get off on having power over their
people including young children and they
brag about it many times by doing photo
shoots let's let's let's let's jump to
this story from Fox Business in in light
of what you're bringing up musk is
planning to release the Twitter files on
Free Speech suppression public deserves
to know so uh of course I sat down with
you know Rogan and and Jack and vagina
and I believe they outright lied to us
that the whole thing was just lies had
they lied under oath too I I don't know
about them but I'm willing to bet
Twitter staff probably have lied on
Underoath the Congress or the very least
they've lied to Congress or even less
than that been wrong to come sure it's
great we'll we'll hear what's going on
I gotta say though the Twitter files I
am I would bet a substantial amount of
money that they have files on child
exploitation where there's a manager
saying like hey don't do anything
because it'll draw attention to us and
it'll be bad for the stock price stuff
like that oh my God would you would you
agree they were probably behind the
scenes I am so I I'm praying with every
fiber of my being that you're wrong like
that's something that's so like purely
evil that to have that in writing it's
it's just so what do you expect
something to these people you're right
you're right but still it's just it's
it's just horrifying to even think about
it why weren't they taking it down
yeah that's a great question that's
that's a very long Elon snaps his finger
that's unfair he's working very hard
getting everybody saying shut it down
and it's disappearing
yeah and and these people at Twitter
were taking advantage of the power and
responsibility they had for their own
personal benefit for the personal
benefit of the power in for the powers
in charge for the government for the
intelligence agencies for the
multinational corporations that are
calling the shots there uh so they're
capable of doing a lot of very
underhanded evil things and I think Elon
Musk even a couple days ago was tweeting
hey you know it's far worse than I even
expected it to be and I bet there's
probably so much evil so much just nasty
actions being committed by these people
that that a lot of people can't even
imagine how how bad it gets let me ask
you uh Ian because you worked for mines
and you actually saw a lot of the
content that violated I can't demand
like based on your experience how bad
you think it is with Twitter people
posting this stuff it's got to be
magnitudes worse because there's
magnitudes more people using it and I
mean like times 10 times 10 times now
there's probably a 10 000 more times
more people using it so I imagine
there's ten thousand times more what I
mean is probably even more than that
because it's a centralized Focus you you
actually had to deal with moderation
when it came to this yeah and I'm
wondering if the FBI went to Twitter and
was like oh that's child porn leave it
up it's a Honeypot now let's see
everybody that shares it and comments on
it those are the people yeah the federal
government has run many adult
um child websites
um and the stories of what they were
doing is absolutely shocking what about
the bonjour boys and is that how it's
pronounced in Afghanistan I don't know
so right yeah our allies in Afghanistan
had a thing where they would bring out
young boys and have their way with them
and basically the uh look this is also
New York Times the U.S armed forces were
told they're on our team look the other
way this isn't our program and then and
then the soldiers that spoke out against
it were court-martialed and punished
that were trying to stop it
your tax dollars were paying for the US
military protecting and aiding small
children being hurt in more ways than
once we want us to come here and make
some Jew jokes you are and they're
hilarious hey the Balenciaga stuff opens
yeah yeah but look look okay we can talk
about I mean what's going on with
Twitter because it's not just obvious
basically the dark dark stuff but we're
probably going to see overt political
bias we're probably going to see
election interference outright them
saying the hunter Biden thing absolutely
there's no question and they're right
interference and they're probably going
to be saying in in the private chats
this is going to help uh Biden win or we
have to stop Trump things like that yeah
yeah there's no question that's it's
dark but I've lightened it yeah no no no
that is that is the
um although the hunter Biden with the
the net with the niece and whatever
that's a whole other situation here we
go again yep no but I I there was this
Norm McDonald uh meme which I don't
think he ever really said uh where the
quote ascribed to Norm which is I'm
starting to think that the the pedophile
devil worshipers who run our government
don't have our best interests at heart
um and there's a lot of Truth to that
yes absolutely I'm wondering what other
when they pull up these Twitter files
that elon's talking about if they're
gonna they're gonna find words that have
been down can I make everyone even more
depressed let's do it hell yes let's do
it please do let's go so uh the thing
that really upsets me is the virtual
certainty that nothing will happen is
their consequence of this and let me
give you an example when this happened
we all remember that Brett Kavanaugh
hearings and the what do you where do
you think of Christine blasey Ford Julie
swetnik was an example where it
absolutely you know she's saying that
Kavanaugh was at these parties where
there was trains run on her it's like
why are you going going back to these
parties Michael avenatti was her lawyer
people were tripping over themselves to
put her on TV it turned out her story
made no sense it didn't add up she never
met Cavanaugh so and so forth
um Chuck Grassley Charles Grassley was
just re-elected who was I think head of
the Judiciary Committee ranking hardcore
Republican he put out a press release
earlier this year how he wrote a letter
to both the Department of Justice and
the FBI asking for follow-up by someone
who lied to you know affect a free Court
nomination and they didn't bother reply
neither bother replying to him and then
he wrote them another letter and this is
his press release see I'm writing
letters that are completely ignored vote
for me so the the fact that he's
boasting about the fact that he can't
even get a like if someone on the phone
from the Department of Justice or the
FBI about something that is Central to
our legal system just speaks to me how
little appetite there is in Washington
among members of both parties to have
any kind of repercussions for this and
another great example of this is I
really drives me crazy when Boomer
conservatives and think oh pedophiles
are Democrats like as if it's somehow
like you know they're into kids but
they're also just socialized medicine
um the Speaker of the House Dennis
Hester was a predator on young boys and
he went to jail as a consequence for
things that have to do with this issue
the Democrats never bring it up they
never use this as a cudgel they never
say why you'd bring back Dennis
hastert's money they're more interested
in talking about like Margaret Taylor
green or Trump or or George W bush who's
now a good guy so that to me is very
very disturbing
I have not given up on politics but I'm
so disinterested in attempting to use
that corrupt system to fix a world that
was we need to make like Politics As a
result of a healthy Society so let's
build a healthy Society then there will
be politics
I'm trying I'm trying to get him to
exercise that's been we had you you said
you wanted to do it yesterday
you need to read this book
you can only help people so much you
gotta open the door they got to walk
through I wanna I wanna mention just as
we're talking about this subject and and
boy are we in it I guess because the
Balenciaga stuff we really needed to
talk about this but there is there there
is a positive for us who are challenging
these things trying to get these things
taken down grateful to Elon Musk for
putting a stop to this and it's that I
was talking to a friend and I said
something like as as semi-facetiously
like oh yeah like you know people
believe that a cabal of powerful Global
Elites are trafficking kids and doing
weird things pause because now we know
they are because of Epstein and
Maxwell's conviction hey that's funny
right if you said that a few years ago
people would call you crazy but
something happened and now we know they
they it happened they're doing it
Maxwell locked up because of it and now
we're still sitting here wondering who
were their clients right so not only do
we know it happened we know there are
still people who have never been held to
account she went down for providing
um you know a service for clients that
weren't there that absolutely doesn't
make sense and and this wasn't the first
time that there have been major
government officials caught in these
larger horrible things that they were
doing to Children Dennis hassert is one
of them the former prime minister of the
United Kingdom Edward Heath another
major I looked him up Ed Heath it's
ambiguous so let's give him some credit
I mean when he's hanging out with Jimmy
Seville I didn't know he was hanging out
with Jimmy Seville yeah I mean Heath was
we don't have receipts on Heath who's
Heath by the way he was the Margaret he
was the Prime Minister the Margaret
Thatcher dethroned I took him out of my
next book yeah but but but again there
are many the gains yes there's we just
keep going how many times and how many
instances there are of government using
your tax dollars to facilitate some of
the most atrocious horrible acts on the
face that people can't even think I
think it was in 1969 1971 uh if you look
up like French philosophers declaration
a bunch of prominent French philosophers
including Star Trek 70s 70s where they
all signed a letter saying that uh age
of consent laws should be abolished wow
yeah it's wild there's there's evil out
there so please look it up okay I want
to talk about evil and cabals because
you're saying these conspiracy theories
people don't know if they're real or not
this is very known right right like the
Epstein stuff is is is it's no longer
the room of conspiracy Maxwell was
convicted I want to shout I want to
shout out uh Phoenix 499 who super
chatted us saying all you need to know
is that Maxwell was the first person to
con to be convicted of trafficking kids
to nobody yeah so so
there's people out there these are evil
people they've gotten away with it for
now
and one more let's get a little personal
I was on Rogan a couple years ago
because a friend of mine Matt and he
told me to use his name he came out to
me because he had been the victim of
childhood sexual abuse and the reason I
bring this up every so often is it's
still one of those things where there's
such a stigma to it that people are
scared to talk about it like if I found
out that your mom you know was was an
alcoholic I'd feel bad for you Luke but
our friendship wouldn't really change if
I found out you know something happened
with you Ian but this is the kind of
thing where people are scared to say
something because if you talk to them
about it they think you're going to
think they're a wounded bird you're
gonna think they're freak you're not
going to be able to make certain kinds
of jokes about them as a result of this
this social stigma they keep it silent
you know for the rest of their lives
which is really really making a victim
even worse and after I was on Rogan I
talked about this four more of my
friends came out to me so if I know five
people that means I definitely know more
that means this happens a lot more than
people realize and until people start
talking about it and normalizing coming
out and accepting people who've had this
done to them they're going to keep
getting away with it because the reason
these people get away with it is like
don't tell anyone and that you're a kid
you're not going to know any better so
it's it's a very very uh disturbing
cycle that hopefully we're going to be
able to break uh in the very near future
you think it's just by normalizing
sexuality adult sexuality in our society
no
like like people are afraid to talk
about sex and then they go and and shame
watch porn and abuse kids like if they
have a healthy conversation about it
maybe it will prevent that kind of
behavior nobody
no I I can't I can't give you this one
we live in the see what I have to deal
with I got to deal with this every day
we are the result of Puritans and they
were very anti like it was Puritan
puritanical has that adjective attached
to it for a reason is because it's like
no sex this might be the most you've
gone full Ian this is the most this is I
almost did porn man I'm like should I be
doing porn right now should I be waking
people up to the idea that sexuality is
okay I I completely agree sexuality is
okay if you want to do porn I'll support
you thank you but I think this is
something very different from people you
know not talking about what kind of sex
they have as opposed to like awful
things were done to me as a kid and they
didn't use force and on some level it
was pleasurable and I was confused
because I was a child and I wasn't
physically hurt they didn't punish me I
didn't know how to feel about the time
and now as an adult I still don't know
how to feel about it and this has
disturb me all my life and I'm turning
to drugs or alcohol because I don't know
how to deal with it like the record my
opinion Hunter Biden perhaps yeah that's
not that's that's a big uh a big can of
worms that we could open up here in just
a little bit but Ian I do not support
your adult uh history you haven't seen
me work yet I do not I do not want to uh
and and there's a big difference between
satanic evil people using like sex as a
way to gain energy and and feel like
they have power over some over actual
genuine love someone let's say way to
censorship because uh I have this I have
a story from law fair Supreme Court
grants certiorari I'm pronouncing that
wrong probably and Gonzalez V Google and
Twitter V tomne an overview
I'm not sure these are the exact cases I
believe these are the cases in question
but I highlight these stories to tell
you that I had a phone call with Google
today
it was scheduled in advance a few weeks
ago I received an email where it was
sent I I believe to larger YouTube
channels warning that section 230
this is The Shield big Tech uses to
eliminate content they they don't like
as distasteful while being immune from
any responsibility due to hosting some
of this content I believe they're on
track to lose these Protections in a
very serious way so Google started doing
this reach out got an email can we focus
on that point because I think it's a big
one in terms of the odds that they're
going to lose I think the odds are very
high they're going to lose because their
argument is we're we're not an editorial
world just a publisher meaning anyone
could put anything out there our hands
are clean however if I'm editorial if
I'm picking articles I'm promoting
people then I am having a voice and
therefore the protections don't apply to
me then I can be guilty of libel or
whatever slander whatever it is and very
clearly all of these uh Instagram
Facebook uh Twitter and YouTube are
putting their finger on the scale and
promoting some things over the other
right I make editorial decisions it's
unambiguous so uh they're panicking yeah
I got an email and it said we want to
make you aware about a supreme court
take taking on these cases which will
have a big impact on recommendations if
the Supreme Court rules against us or
our position we may not be able to
recommend your content anymore and you
know what I thought when I saw that Ian
should do porn
I thought maybe maybe
um that's a good one but no I left
are are you kidding me that they would
email this when we know for a fact they
suppress our content and I say we know
for a fact because let me let me let me
tell you this I get a phone call from
the guy
we had a meeting I get the email it says
please schedule here's my availability I
don't want to be mean to the guy he
called me and he was advocating for his
position I respect that he wants to talk
to me again tomorrow
I scheduled the meeting for whatever
date was available and uh we had some
emergency stuff going on today obviously
we had a heck of a yesterday so you know
of course we get slammed with a bunch of
stuff today you get it but I get a phone
call I'm in the car and I'm like well I
answer it anyway and I'm like hey I'm in
the car and I'm like FaceTiming this
dude and he basically was was explaining
that if the Supreme Court
agrees with these people
that means YouTube look section 230 says
you can't sue I'll I'll give a
simplified version can't sue YouTube
because of what Tim Paul says I am
putting something out there YouTube did
not say it however it also says YouTube
can't be considered a publisher or of
his content even if they moderate and
have editorial control over the platform
now how do you have it both ways
separation you always have it both ways
right so uh so they call me and they say
listen
it may be and this is so hilarious the
guy's like look we we might not be able
to issue recommendations anymore that
means search because we use an algorithm
so if someone imagine someone searched
for your name and the and the videos
wouldn't come up
and I'm just sitting there like oh you
imagine it huh imagine it huh I went off
I'm sorry I snapped I said we we hit 800
000 views on our video no trending no
recommendations there was a period where
Google
removed this YouTube channel from all of
their search you could type in the title
of a video and I was like and you're
gonna call me and tell me that I should
be worried about this you understand
that you have so much weight against me
we succeed in spite of what you've done
that if YouTube strips you of your
powers we'll actually benefit from it
yeah two points first people at home
don't realize that when Tim gets this
angry his beanie becomes a mushroom
cloud so it's kind of really cool to
watch and I'm the victim of this too on
Instagram you can't search for my name
you can't even tag me you have to spell
out Michael malice because I'm
completely Saturday on Instagram if you
try to follow me it gives you a warning
telling you not to follow me because I'm
I spread quote misinformation you try to
tag me it says don't you sure you want
to tag this guy misinformation you're
bad you're badass YouTube has been
screwed me for for in my entire career
what you described Tim has been
happening throughout my entire career
YouTube promotes authoritative sources
CNN MSNBC fake news spreaders they don't
spread Independents
and it's almost impossible to find
Eden's pornos I have looked a lot that's
awesome look on the Cross Match I want
to tell you more about what this guy was
saying I'm not actually porn on there he
said something to the effect of imagine
if we could no longer recommend you and
you are no longer part of like I'm
paraphrasing something like the the
mainstream conversation or something and
I'm just like guy that's what you've
already done we created a new Channel
timcast music we put up a video on it it
gets half a million views in a day two
days later it is trending number 23 our
number I think number 23 on YouTube
surprise surprise a brand new Channel
with a big video gets play We're
trending but IRL can get half a million
views on an episode in two hours and
never reach that Mark can I make a point
my understanding is from someone who has
inside knowledge about this that the
trending up section on YouTube is manual
right of course so so it's not organic I
think it's a mix but I think it's
largely editorial yeah I think there's
obviously a component but my you know my
point was to the guy said why is it that
we know for a fact you can't Google
search my videos
like Facebook comes up you can't even
you can't even search my channel when
you would search for Tim cast or Tim
cast IRL it would it would just show you
playlists created by other people
because they removed us from search and
you're telling me that you want the
ability to be free from all liability
when you choose to promote political
speech from say Isis but then you expect
me to defend you when you put the
weights on us when we call out these bad
players I hope I said this to him I hope
that that the Supreme Court rules
against you and everything is forced to
return to reverse chronological feed
because I will do better from it uh
absolutely but this talks earlier about
how the suits are often oblivious
because I bet you any money that he had
the exact same speech for everyone who
was trying to call he had a list of like
50 people and he had the exact same
speech as to who's talking to and then
the call got disconnected I guess he he
that was us we control the phones and we
didn't like that
um maybe he got disconnected but uh as I
was talking and I'm I'm heated but I was
being played out like a nine minutes not
you personally but dude don't call me
and think I'm gonna side with you on
this one I don't think he did his
research I just love the idea that like
you're gonna holler up like tanji brown
Jackson and be like come on and she's
like all right like I've got to rule and
favor them no no right but but I also
thought that it was kind of funny that
Google thinks they can start calling
creators and saying support our
Authority they can I bet you a lot of
these creators are completely art
synthetic and a function of their
algorithm but I'm also willing to bet
that when he calls leftists they said
this same thing I did LGBT creators have
been complaining a long time that
YouTube suppresses that because it's not
Advertiser friendly so they're going to
call them and be like defend our
immunity they're gonna say no restore
reverse chronological feed so that we
can have my my video can be shown to my
followers I bet you there's a lot of
people who are happy to play ball
because if you look at any industry the
people that top are often happy to lick
the boot there's there's always some
Ralphs willing to suck up to power and
authority but I think a lot of people
are absolutely frustrated and pissed off
at these algorithms controlling our
society that have been absolutely a net
negative not just to the mental health
of this country but when we see the the
mental Warfare that that's being created
out there what are you you're going to
be doing something here what do you mean
by algorithms say it name them well like
like I I'm not going to you know bat an
eye when the same huge organization that
labeled me a conspiracy theorist now
won't be able to editorialize I'm not
going to be mad at that it's it's
totally fine let people see what they
want to see it's that simple if they
subscribe to something if they want to
see something let them see it we're
adults here stop treating us like
children I don't want to be recommended
these stupid RV videos or these stupid
truck life videos I don't want to be
recommended some kind of psyop stop with
the psyopsis stop with the nonsense I
want to listen to what I want to listen
to and that's what the people demand and
that's what the people will get I'm on
Twitter and they have their algorithmic
feed and their their home feed that's
what it's called and they have the
reverse chronological feed
I do really well posting my content and
getting shares and getting followers
without any kind of weird algorithmic
impedance so YouTube deserves to have
that stripped away from them I my
Twitter following went up uh in by an
order of quadruple new followers a day
when some switch got switched 10 days
ago and Ben askren who is now oh for
three uh my Show episode with him is
dropping next week when we recorded he
had more followers than me and was
rubbing at my face and now I have 10 000
more than him so suck at aspirin I now I
know what Jake Paul feels point being
there was clearly some kind of
algorithmic screwry on the back end that
was hurting me before and he's either
neutral helping me now yeah I got I
experienced the same thing probably you
too Tim have you heard there's like that
internet meme law that says any online
Forum uh without moderation will become
right uh something like that any any
online Forum without sufficient
moderation will become right wing oh
okay yeah I think it's more like it'll
become radicalized
Conquest Laws of Power the second one is
any organization not dedicated to being
right-wing will become left-wing so that
might be an inversion of that really
yeah I guess that that's the assumption
that the the powers that be right now
have been co-opted by some sort of
leftist mentality right sort of
communist or socialist uh move well but
uh I you know so I don't know where that
Meme came from but you take a look at
like Reddit
pre-syop control by uh you know big
powerful packs and organizations yeah
the memes were all like well that's
where the Donald came from right exactly
and and uh I think it was MIT technology
review said that the Donald and 4chan's
Politically Incorrect were the
progenitors of almost all of the memes
that were going viral they were funny
people liked them the Pepes they'd end
up on Twitter and then Katy Perry was
sharing them no moderation it was just
meritocratic the best memes Rose to the
top everyone liked it shared it that
culture built and then all of a sudden
they had what leads us to dead internet
Theory this emergency Panic session
where moderation comes in like crazy
there's uh Michael Tracy tweeted this
Twitter's rules from 2015. pre this big
emergency meeting was basically don't
incite violence but we will not
intervene in any disputes between people
now it's we take a political stance
hardcore Etc yeah YouTube in 2006 when I
started June 2006 on the cross Mac
Channel go check it out it's uh it was
all owned by YouTube Google had not
bought the company yet that was like a
year and a half later and they were just
featuring whatever they wanted every day
there'd be 10 featured videos every day
and throughout the day they drop down
one every like two hours you know a new
one would come up so you'd be slowly
siphon off the front page it was all
idealistically motivated whoever was
controlling YouTube at that time was
deciding it was Steve Grove who was
running politics was like I like your
video Ian I'm gonna feature it in news
and politics so he liked it their his
political are both our political agenda
got pushed which was real like Barack
Obama but then at some point Google
bought the company I saw that's
dangerous that's corporate
conglomeration this could be really bad
people started getting banned and uh
then the politics people knew people
probably came into the power of the in
control so since the beginning it's been
a platform and a public like they are
platform they are deciding who gets to
be seen since the very beginning I think
Elon Musk has shown us a lot of what
this is big advertisers are scared
because left-wing activists organize and
they they organize predominantly on
Twitter these campaigns against them now
there's uncertainty and they don't know
what to do I think it's funny
advertisers announced that they were
going to pull off their ads or reduce
spending on Twitter due to uncertainty
and my personal view is the uncertainty
likely is which side is going to attack
us more and we don't know who to side
with anymore same thing this is how uh
Times Square for Pride became all
rainbows you know 25 8. uh I've tweeted
this before that only Corporate America
can make sodomy and perversion seem
downright boring uh but before gay
marriage became universally accepted in
corporate culture they just kept their
mouth shut like they would have these
little organizations days like oh you
know we have this little program but now
you buy a candy bar and it's you know
it's a rainbow it's got a rainbow flag
on it and talking about the Skittles
except except for their their brands
that operate in like the Middle East or
whatever those ones that never don't
they have a banned substance and
Skittles that was recently found out
that was absolutely really horrible hold
on I don't think that's that's where
there's I don't think that's where they
hide the arena currents do you think
that we should Advocate to ban corporate
advertisement in social media no
what really that's such a First
Amendment are you communist yeah
Michael keeps looking at me when Ian
says stuff with this look of like I
can't believe he's social media is a con
is I love him and I'm in love with him
it's working I love you too Michael you
know he says something and you look at
me
it's super serious yeah because I think
the huge social media networks I means
the ones that I think where their code
should be freed like they're working in
the Commons and at some point if the
advertisers are controlling the commons
by by blackmail or by saying we will
take our money away if you don't do what
we say that's the bad for the commons I
I don't disagree with that but what I'm
saying is this is something that you're
trying to kind of square a circle and
there's no easy answer one way or
another if you're gonna have a
subscription model then it's gonna be
kind of Karen oriented because the ones
who complain the most are going to have
disproportionate amounts of power so
things are going to be kind of
inoffensive so I don't see an easy
answer here right because if you remove
advertisers from YouTube for instance
all these people with the partner
program are I don't think it's called
the partner program anymore it's
something else but everybody would start
losing their ad Revenue yeah that could
destroy by tens of thousands of careers
you know I think Elon recognized the
power of cancel culture and what they
were doing I don't think it's the sole
component of why he bought Twitter but
you can see him tweeting at Tim Cook
apparently the financial times reported
that he was calling CEO saying why are
you dropping us I think Elon knows the
fear they have of Twitter
I think anybody
I think most of you most people
listening understand this if you've got
Twitter followers and you have a problem
and you tweet about it that company
bends over backwards to help you I don't
like the system I think it's really wait
wait wait wait wait hold up let's hold
the phone you know I've got a lot of
Twitter followers I can make problems
for people just by calling someone no no
you can get whatever you want wait I I
want the I want what I want okay so
here's an example
um if you if you are boarding a plane
you can just oh yeah I had a terrible
experience oh yeah of course this is
horrible and they'll say We'll upgrade
you we're so sorry we'll give you
whatever you want wait you really
yes I can do this
I was sitting in the middle seat on my
flight here and let me tell you as soon
as I got off the plane I talked to the
manager from Tim cast and I certainly
were you on a middle seat I was in a
middle seat not like an animal Sydney
Watson
between two large larger people
according to Sid was that a quarter she
had receipts but the point I was making
just just try and stay on subject I
suppose is um
when you have a lot of followers and you
have a problem with a company you tweet
about it they will take care of you
because they know you can direct a lot
of bad reviews customer it's it's
negative advertising Twitter has created
a negative advertising space I I'm going
to Tweet at White Castle right now I
hate them they're really not good I'm
not joking it's inedible so let's see
what happens hold on hold on hold on you
misunderstand
I'm tweeting I have three burgers I
don't want White Castle with like cat
sliders yeah a little guy so like
imagine imagine this Elon Musk has 120
million followers done so when he says
Apple's pulling ads or Apple's
threatening to drop Twitter from the
platform and then he tweets directly at
Tim Cook Tim Cook is on blast his phone
starts
and he's going what's going on he's like
oh no elon's tweeting at me oh man he's
got 120 million followers what's
happened according to Financial Times is
that when Elon calls the CEOs they
reinstate their ads but to a minimum
level okay to keep the money flowing
these ad networks are terrified of
whoever controls the communication
sphere and now Elon has it okay well it
looks like Elon has it but what whose
money is Elon using I told you not to
talk about on the air mobile Bankers
money that they can turn off your
account at any moment we found with
Kanye's situations so let's talk about
who controls social media it's banking
I mean it's the money but you think Elon
isn't acting under his own volition I
think he is within the bounds that he's
given which is this is your US dollar
this is how you get by this is how you
get food you're you're not completely
off but there is agency among the
individual right Elon is very powerful
this is the point I'm making he has
Twitter he can wield 120 million
followers that's why they're scared to
go too hard against them because you
look at what look at what's going on in
China right now even with the power and
the Iron Fist of the CCP people have
have reached their point so there are
powerful interests there are people and
it's self-interest too like these big
corporations they don't like that Elon
can push him around there are powerful
government interests they also don't
like the light of the spotlight on them
they want to stay like okay you know the
reason how it works is with like black
lives matter you don't want to be that
one corporation that didn't have that
black Square it's much easier to go with
the herd because then no one could pick
you off so when he calls someone or puts
them on blast all of a sudden there's no
good answer for you as a corporate
because now you're like I'm gonna offend
somebody and that's my nightmare
scenario their stock price will drop
yeah negative stock price yeah I mean I
don't know if it actually is it by three
percent oh is that right I just saw a
clip uh uh okay screenshot yeah and and
they know that and they're like a three
percent drop is how how many billions of
dollars exactly like how many less
iPhones are we gonna sell and how much
an ad revenue is that gonna like if we
spend 10 billion on ads how many or 10
million or whatever yes Apple stock
price is down two percent well a lot of
stocks are down but uh seeing the war
between Elon and apple is pretty uh
glorious it's pretty amazing
it's it's spectacular to see because you
know Elon even said hey you know if this
gets too crazy if you guys ban us from
the Apple Store we're just gonna create
our own phone which you should do yeah I
think is awesome and I think the the
market is going to provide a solution to
a lot of the censorious a lot of the
insane algorithms and control systems
that is trying to of course suck out
Humanity from um you know existence well
do you you think that the government
should strip 230 protections from these
companies I I think if if we have you
know organizations they're using these
kind of speech platforms using uh what
what is essentially our modern day town
halls and censoring people
editorializing people I think
um that right there is them taking
advantage of a situation and what should
be the larger Rama what should be the
larger solution to that I I think you
know they do have a monopoly I think
it's fair to say that and and I think it
needs to be broken apart oh God oh my
God okay now you go to the show you both
can go back to Russia okay okay how do
you how do you deal with with Google how
do you deal with this problem because
because like state power obviously yeah
because they are they are an institution
that is a part of the State uh right
wait I'm not arguing there there's
there's absolutely intertwine between
the them in the state yeah you can't
like break up Twitter like that doesn't
really no I'm not saying breakup okay
I'm saying stop stop the governor
working with Twitter needs to stop
immediately you need to be broken up and
not have this unfair advantage that the
government gives them I hardly endorse
literally everything he just said okay
thank you I appreciate I know you got
scared there I did I don't I don't you
know trust me I don't want I don't want
more states to solve the problem of the
state you're getting all Sherman no no
no no no no no no I'm not I'm not
getting there I'm just saying yes no
you're right the state empowers these
monopolies the state needs to stop
immediately section 230 is government
protection for big corporations to be
free from any liability for what they
publish recommend or otherwise while
they are also simultaneously free to
editorialize and promote whatever they
want that is insane imagine if we had a
law in this country that said you as a
newspaper can never be sued for
defamation but but it's ridiculous this
is one of the big Arguments for
anarchism meaning of separation of
government of Commerce and state for the
same reasons you have separation of
church and state because we saw with the
pharmaceutical companies which is this
deal on behalf of literally everyone in
America where you are going to make your
shot I don't even know what words I can
say on YouTube anymore and we really
needed to rush to Market understandably
under an emergency kind of unprecedented
situation but as a result of this
they're going to be no consequences for
you if things go bad yeah it couldn't
even be like you know what here's what's
going to happen if things go bad we as
the government are going to make some
kind of welfare and pay out for people
who had consequences for our wrongdoing
just like if there's certain other
situations like you're in war and you're
a soldier and you come back we're going
to take care of you they didn't even do
that they're just gonna be like you know
what no one's gonna be responsible and
that to me is government at its most
malevolent no liability at all which is
absolutely criminally insane especially
when there are clearly a lot of people
getting hurt by this they have no one to
go to who's going to be paying for their
medical bills who's going to be taking
care of them there's no ability to have
any kind of restitution at all which is
insane or even acknowledgment of
wrongdoing exactly
just here's the blank check yeah go for
it no there's no blank check there's
nothing there's Shut Up Get Away we told
you to do this we manipulated you to do
this we extorted you to do this we told
you you can't travel you can't live you
can't go see your grandma die unless you
do this you did this you got hurt who's
who's responsible no one you're
responsible for believing us that's
that's essentially what they're saying
at the end of the day here relatively
recently in history that they did that
too right what that they made the uh no
this has been going on since like Teddy
Rose I was gonna say vaccine immunity oh
no sorry I'm not like monopolies being
able to do what they want yeah in fact
protections are probably the new thing
vaccine immunity protection no no no no
no no corporate protections corporate
corporations aren't uh what do you know
when the first Corporation was oh I I
bet this has been issues since like the
1890s I don't know what First
Corporation was it might be the 1890s
around then I'm not sure I don't think
so I think it's got to be earlier well
there is in a trading company I know
yeah exactly yeah that was like a
country man that was so right basically
but uh you think you had any rights
working for the East India Trading
Company they would issue script like
their own currency that you you'd have
to use on their territory to buy like
food from their stores and imagine what
would happen if they're like we want you
to go take this machete and go clear
Bush what if I get hurt they just laugh
like how could you even ask that
question do it or don't eat
now because you're replaceable right
there's no shortage of people from
Ireland or Eastern Europe you know we
can kind of fill your shoes it's only
recently in human history we started
saying like hey you know people should
be responsible if they're misleading if
they're causing problems or at the very
least if there is a if if like you
release a toy that has an issue that
needs to be recalled and you don't
people get like you you'll get sued
you're responsible something someone
hurts you the party that hurt you is
responsible is liable the government
steps in says no they're not liable but
also to add insults to injury they're
also acting like the pr agency of big
Pharma if we look at within the last few
years that the White House has
essentially become a a marketing an
advertisement arm of big Pharma and
other multinational corporations that
they agree with that enforce their
agenda that to me is another layer of
Communism that we have to deal with
that's absolutely insane and needs to
stop immediately I feel so redundant
yeah he's saying all my things like what
do I what do I do here like oh I need
you here when the status are here when
the collectivists when the Communists
when the right Wingers who want more
government here I need you here to talk
about this thank you oh my God this is
this is please let's talk about this
because this is something that blew my
mind because it really drives me crazy
how conservatives use the word communist
in the same way that progressives use
the word racist just means something I
don't like I was on The Blaze on
Election night and Steve deese who's a
Christian conservative who I was very
impressed by he was very very bright uh
he really kind of understand how
politics works but his conclusion at the
end was to have Twitter be run as a
public utility by the government and I'm
like you're fighting communism by having
these organizations be run by the state
under socialist that's literally
socialism and then people take it even
further by saying you know I think I
know what's better for everyone I think
they need this in their life and that in
the life and we need the state to
mandate this and this and this and I'm
like you're sounding exactly like what
you're fighting against because they're
supposedly fighting against exactly the
leftists are making the same argument
saying I know it's better for you I know
what's right for you and this is why we
need the state to intervene and use
their Monopoly of violence in order to
push my Wills onto you and I'm like stop
violating human rights when the
conservatives talk about we need to be
teaching Morality In Schools that's what
CRT is that is progressives teaching
their Morality In Schools let's we'll
have a conversation about this okay
um I think you can do something like put
Twitter under government control that's
not communism or socialism it may be
socialistic but it would also enshrine
theoretically First Amendment
protections on on this platform that's
become a weapon for one political
faction yeah but look at like NPR right
like NPR is uh heavily subsidized by the
state and they're so are they though
small minorly I believe it's very low
percent surprisingly then why are they
allowed to call themselves why were they
called Federal Express exactly it's it's
totally misleading and it should be
illegal well you can't call yourself
like there was like an issue calling
yourself Bank of something that like
this was a big issue because it was
really well I've been told good for me I
don't know what if I were right what if
I called my company official U.S
government
Post Office business or so official U.S
government candy that was the name of my
company I mean that would have to be
illegal that makes no sense it would
make the kids change their genders when
you look it up and made this as wrong it
says NPR does not receive any Direct
Federal funding it receives small
competitive grants from cpb and federal
agencies like the Department of
Education and the Department of Commerce
and see so how are they funded if they
don't do they have advertising from
viewers like you oh I think it's mostly
money independent money but more power
I'm not I'm not actually kind of crazy
where they get that away from I don't
want to come out and say I think I I you
know I definitely agree that the problem
is government uh I think all Power
Systems tends to tend towards corruption
over time yes and the problem is that
government programs Can't Fail they're
so there there are like they're
surrounded by the Monopoly on violence
like Luke was saying and so they could
never just stop so perhaps Sunset
Clauses in anything is like maybe a
constitutional amendment all government
programs and laws will have a five-year
Sunset must be revoted upon by the
people or something like that the
problem with that is if you look at like
a trademark law right it used to be that
that after X amount of years a character
becomes public domain and Disney is just
lobbying Congress so Mickey Mouse and
Superman because they're made in the 30s
should have been public domain that I
know how many years ago meaning anyone
can make a Superman movie anyone can
make a Mickey Mouse movie and they just
keep pushing the bucket down the road
because there's such an asymmetry Disney
has a huge interest in this the rest of
us have a little power or interest in
this it's it's the Symmetry is never
going to be in the favor of the freedom
I think agreed in regards to how you
deal with a monopolistic social media
Network I kind of agree I don't want the
government controlling who gets to say
what on the network because that's just
another kind of Monopoly if the
government was to be like no we're in a
monopoly it's just popular like it it's
very difficult to have several search
engines because one is effectively going
to be much more optimal than the others
yeah and because it's better it's become
maybe you're right maybe the word
monopoly is not the right word but I
feel like Google has a monopoly on
internet search they maybe not because
Brave is there DuckDuckGo exists but
like if those other things had a
competitive Advantage for some way
because Google beat Yahoo I'm old enough
to know Yahoo as the search engine there
was Alta Vista and there was web crawler
and there's Ask Jeeves I don't know if
those still exist but the point is
Google won because their search results
were more useful so I don't know how you
would even beat Google in that regard
well I don't think you can
what you can do is there's that film
sorry about myself there was the film
The creepy line which they put which is
what they really should be going after
is how Google operates and as an example
if I am searching for let's suppose the
guy Robert uh I forget Robert Levine
maybe his name was uh the professor
let's suppose I'm searching for Hillary
Clinton right and Google makes it so the
top 10 search results are articles that
are positive toward Hillary Clinton and
if I search for Donald Trump Google
makes it so the top 10 articles are
critical of Donald Trump that is going
to skew the electorate one way or
another and all of us would be oblivious
to see that Google has their their thumb
on the scale so that is the kind of
thing where the government can be
investigating and being like all right
uh something here is not adding up
because you're acting as a political
agency and in that case there's all
sorts of things that go with it all I
come to is to I mean the audience served
this before probably but free the
software code yes yes Amen brother I
agree with Ian on that in terms of so we
know the algorithms that are managed yes
yes but not the property line of it
right correct you know I would bring in
experts to talk about what x action
really needs to be freed I don't think
it's every ounce of lettering in every
code base and I should have him on the
guy who he got he like he got kicked off
of Gmail because of this like he
basically did the work and he's like we
like for example another thing he found
is like Facebook they would if you liked
Hillary they would hit you with you
should go out and vote if you like Trump
uh Robert Epstein yeah I think that's
the name yes correct hell yeah
no relationship you can't search for him
anymore yes what a surprise psychologist
he was basically saying that the the
search algorithm was flip was flipping
votes yeah and the way he described it
not only does it make perfect sense
you'd have no way of knowing yep then
there was many there was even many
scientific studies detailing how big
Tech social media companies can swing
elections and help candidates win when
they had no chance of winning during the
uh there were Twitter hearings in
Congress
Republican brought up that when you were
in DC
and you sign up for Twitter Twitter
recommends Democrats and only Democrats
wow
he was like why is it
this is what you get well let's play
Devil's Advocate it could be that the
DC's overwhelming Democrat right so if
the odds are if you're in DC you want to
follow Democrat and that and that's you
know when I did this phone call with
this guy that's basically he was saying
he's like don't you want us to be able
to show you what you want
and I'm like I want to be shown what I
choose to watch yeah you know I like
this is the way they think we know what
you want more than you do you know
sometimes I get these Instagram ads and
I end up buying a UFO and then buying a
second UFO
um because it was a cool ad wait where's
the second one at Adam craigler's house
it's gone yeah unfortunate well this is
the second one how much are those it's
like 200 bucks okay this is cool I saw
it on Instagram and I'm like oh I want
to get that and so they kind of figured
it out you know I want something right
but when it comes to political content
it doesn't work the same way right it
becomes extremely nightmarish when you
start this this is what I was explaining
to Dorsey and vajayagade that if they
keep doing what they're doing there's
going to be uh I don't think I said the
word Civil War back then but maybe maybe
if you go watch the episode because what
I was trying to get to is you're
basically you're forcing everyone into
into yep you are creating 100
polarization on purpose and they were
like whatever they didn't care but I
think all in their def their defense of
using that term very Loosely the thing
is with social media and you have these
conversations it works kind of
evolutionarily in that anyone's
philosophy is going to be driven to its
logical conclusion because you run
enough iterations that any kind of
contradictions are kind of going to go
away and you're going to go towards the
extreme or The Logical conclusion of
wherever the premises are so that is why
kind of in many ways this moderate
middle is is Vanishing because being in
the middle is not really a coherent
position it's just kind of a reaction to
these two other polls yeah the middle
can be like extreme right left really
fast so fast that it looks like it's in
the middle so it's still there's still a
balance in the extremes if you can
handle it hopefully most people can I
mean you kind of have to when you're on
social media because it's so extreme
when you log on it's so extreme
everything is so extreme it's like not
everything it's like Mountain Dew they
got me talking extreme I'm curious some
people have suggested that Elon musk's
moves are actually against the right
because uh there's this idea I've talked
about you have two kids one is covered
in filth and dirt and mud and the other
looks beautiful and pristine with a nice
little suit and tie on let's call them
Ian and Luke Ian and Luke and so
hear me out when you approach this woman
and you see one child smeared with ice
cream all over his face that was my
chance
you blew it when you see a kid all messy
covered in ice cream and one kid who's
looking very clean you assume man that
kid must be unruly and crazy that kid
must be responsible in reality the mom
just doesn't give the clean the kid
who's clean any treats or or or reprieve
and is mean to him
the kid was messy gets whatever he wants
they're both actually bad kids what
happens on Twitter is they start
removing people on the right okay this
is bad you're gone bad you're gone and
all that's left are moderate and
moderate conservatives to Center you
know like center right to Modern
conservative voices and on the left they
say you can do whatever you want so you
end up with antifa violence extremist
posts
so so it's skews and ends up making the
left look insane
Elon comes in and I'm not saying he's
doing this on purpose maybe he's just
genuinely like free speech some people
are saying allowing everybody back on
who's Crazy is going to actually end up
making the right look bad because it's
going to bring back the worst possible
voices but I don't think he hasn't first
of all he hasn't brought back Carpe
dunked him who's like the number one on
my list because carpet donkton was
making memes for Trump uh there's no
reason for him to be banned it's
completely crazy so Elon please bring
back Carpe doctor you brought back well
he's bringing back everyone he's
bringing back tens of thousands users
very soon so is he bringing back
everyone is he bringing up Milo Chuck
Johnson he he did a poll saying a
blanket amnesty for anyone that didn't
spam or or clearly violate the bigger
rules yeah but everyone's going to be
back there's that asterisk 62 000 people
fine my point is we don't know that
that's going to include the people who
were like where Twitter had previously
regarded as the worst the worst I agree
I agree
um like Jones he's out there said he
wouldn't bring him back does this mean
he will that was interesting they asked
someone asked Elon I think it was uh
Viva Frey maybe Viva fry David how do
you say your last name for right uh if
he would bring back Alex and he was like
no no I have no respect for people that
would I'm paraphrasing what elon's
response was in text that uh he values
children and anyone that would demean
and use children for political gain or
power he's totally disgusting that's all
of Washington and that's an example of
like you're gonna let one guy run
yourself I've responded to that do you
know what Obama did in the Middle East
and how many weddings and children he
bombed but it's an example of like you
let one guy run a network he has total
emotional control of who gets to play
what's that emotional I think he's
making a coherent if incorrect in your
opinion perspective yeah but it I mean
he's not allowed I think he paid the
price for saying those things in public
and Free Speech I mean he's done his you
know he's I hate can we talk about this
I really really hate that term free
speech I don't ever use it uh because it
means so many different things to
different people like some people think
oh if you're blocking me you're blocking
my free speech it's like if I'm not
letting him in the house no there's a
lot of conservatives to say that too oh
you're all yeah I thought you're for
free speech and now you block me off
your page because I'm I'm an idiot who's
babbling Mega stuff did you tell them
that freedom of speech doesn't mean
freedom from consequences well I can't
reply them once they're blocked oh yeah
that's the argument because is it free
speech to go on Twitter and say all
these racist stuff and then you get
banned it's still elon's free speech to
block whoever he wants but then you're
like well is it a public company is it a
private company now we're in New
Territory free speech is a principle
it's like an ethic it's a it's a
position that we hold culturally at
least we did for a long time until you
know culture started shifting I guess
everybody opposes Free Speech when they
can knock them from power as opposed to
getting degrees I remember being a small
kid being like yeah it's a free country
I could say what I want now now we don't
have that on Twitter if you are allowed
to go on and say your opinions as
repugnant as they may be that is free
speech if Elon Musk says some opinions
are not allowed he does not believe in
free speech Free Speech there there are
reasonable limits I think is fair I
don't think doxing should be allowed and
that is First Amendment protected speech
so you know even I am not an absolutist
here let's talk about doxing if
someone's uh like contact information is
public right like under in a phone book
whatever it is and you republish that do
you consider that to be doxing
that's tough right that's a tough one
right is it is it doxing if someone just
Google someone you could find their I
don't think that actually qualifies but
I don't like it I I think that's really
kind of egregious and I think you guys
would probably agree
I think it is egregious yeah right the
government also sells your addresses
many times through the DMV through
private corporations is that right later
you could buy yeah people's their
services online where you could where
people go and buy government Registries
and then have people's addresses where
people could buy it online and find out
where they live it's like if I send your
address to one person is that doxing if
I send it to 10 now is that if it's a
hundred like at what point does it
become a docs I think it becomes a box
when you're sending it to Strangers Like
Pub so if it's public does it or private
leads to strangers to straight people I
don't know yeah I think or with the
intent certainly it kind of plays into
here like this is something it's not
like hey wish Ian a happy birthday send
them a card to his address
it's a fine line we got to respect
people's privacy but also at the same
time we got to respect people's speech
where do you draw the line yeah because
I'm allowed to say what your address is
I'm allowed yeah in public under the
first amendment doxing is is protected
you can hold up a big sign with
someone's edges and walk around with it
it's actually also really kind of crazy
I'm reading biography autobiography of
this woman Mabel Dodge Luhan who had
these salons in her house in the early
20th century where modernism started and
the articles in the New York Times would
be like Mrs Mabel Dodge comma of five
East 23rd Street New York and it would
just have her address there it's like
this seems like it's a problem yeah well
I guess
culture is the is is the biggest issue
in my opinion when it comes to
everything most of the political stuff
we're dealing with is cultural when you
have a culture that is cohesive and
agrees on morals and ethics like you can
leave your door open at night
you don't have to worry as much about
crime but when you have a a society a
country where everyone's just like
you're not a part of my community I
don't know you I don't care now you got
to lock your doors
it seems like when you have small
localities there tends to be a
homogenization of culture because
there's only 70 of us you know we all
know where 7th Street is but as soon as
you introduce a hundred thousand or 10
million unknowns to the culture you're
in a state of like I can't leave my I
can't leave my address online anymore
because we used to have the Yellow Pages
yeah like there used to be books this
used to be the big appeal of cities that
if you're from some small town or ever
knew your business you could go
somewhere and get lost and vanish and
that it's not just that thing for
criminals it could be things like you
know I want to ReDiscover myself I want
to have create a new identity for myself
I want to get away from this kind of
upbringing I had so this was back in the
day of benefit of cities but thanks to
the internet that's kind of gone away I
don't need to go live proximately to
people who share my world if I could
just find it through social media so on
and so forth and given how just
deleteriously cities have been
collapsing in the last 10 years in terms
of just basic safety and and public
services is it's just the the question
on the table I think for many of us is
are cities an outdated mode of of
organization or or our governments
because yes
way way more government than a lot of
other places that have a lot less
government you guys are menarchists
that's the most insulting thing they
could ever tell me to my face
I know worse than that like you said you
said that social media needs a little
bit there's a fight those are fighting
earlier I think you were saying about
Twitter that my goodness maybe you are
you I have a machete here you're down to
to break up monopolies with government
is that what you're like you said
earlier that you want the government to
be involved
so much do you see what I have to deal
with everything you told me you're a
minor
I've never had to my face here like nine
years ago Anarchist maybe but no zero
government because then the corporations
just take control the corporation oh my
God every day yeah please read this okay
sentence one sentence if you have a job
that's basically a government but think
about corporations can become a
government if they're unchecked the only
entity or institution anywhere for any
reason at any point that could make a
road is the government
a socialized government can protect free
roads for people better than a
corporation in my opinion but that's
your opinion is you sound like Jason
with luck your opinion's based on
nothing I love Jason's based on nothing
we can look very quickly to find out
private roads versus public roads and
how safe they are how often they break
down potholes things like this and it's
not even equ cost well hold on you know
when when the government builds the road
there's a simple solution to the
potholes KFC comes in and fills them and
then it was Domino's who did that oh
okay yes what you were saying I think
the evidence would be that corporations
are authoritarian by Nature you have one
person in control that decides who stays
who goes and if they control a busy
roadway well I'm triggered you do this I
can't help it I deal with this every day
at your turn so so um a busy roadway for
instance if of course if Google owned
you know I-76 I'd rather talk to Kanye
most people might might might agree with
you you have an opportunity he's going
to storm out yeah so what do you do if
we got a both storm if alphabet or
Microsoft owned like I-77 North and then
you and then like tomorrow we don't want
any black people on that road and you're
like where's our government to protect
us from The Psychotic Corporation oh
okay so let's walk through this uh
thought experiment and I've never used
the word thought more Loosely what do
you think would happen to alphabet if
they publicly said we are going to have
a part of our company that is forbidden
for use by black people forgetting
lawsuits and discrimination law
literally what do you think would happen
to that company antifa would show up
with crowbars that's the only thing
would happen the stock price
overnight um well let's think about this
who controls the stock market who what
if they what if people tried to storm
the headquarters antifa overnight and
they have armed guards outside that
killed them all and where's the
government to stop that from happening
okay I I'm talking about this peacefully
forget antifa if a company declares we
are not going to have part of our
organization accessible to black people
do you think there will be no extreme
immediate consequences for that company
I would hope that there were but I think
that when Vanderbilt shut off the
railroads through New York there was
obviously there comes times where he had
so much control system
a general a general um boycott isn't
enough because it controls so much
aspects of society already I I think
this is you don't even need a boycott
because anyone who's a publicly traded
company is there at the behest of the
stock owners and the board so if I am
whoever's running alphabet now I'd even
know his name and say first of all I
don't even know how they're Sundar I
don't even know how they're going to get
this plan through but if someone just if
let's Elon if Elon Musk tomorrow says
all right here's the new rule on Twitter
no one who's black can be on Twitter and
that even includes uh well uh what's his
name
um Sean whatever
Sean King even sean King you're not a
Comics thank you he's not allowed on
Twitter the number of audience would
implode the number of news articles
would be through the roof and the stock
price would be nothing and all that
money that he's owed I don't know how
that would work but those Banks would
call him that debt yeah so you might be
right because of the because of the
emotional charge about racism you're
right there could be reactions now let's
take something more Insidious BlackRock
wants to buy Farmland in the United
States what if they buy it all where's
our government protection do you under
okay do you understand how what
determines price
um ideally no not ideally supply and
demand but I mean it's so as literally
so it's who if they're colluding they
can uh the government decides you can't
stop you can't set your prices you know
we have protection so that the
corporations aren't deciding what the
price is well wait so if I am buying
let's suppose just eggs right the more
eggs I buy the higher the price of eggs
becomes right and then it becomes
asymptotic right in a in like a
mechanical system that's supposed to
happen real estate is a great example of
this like Austin and New York as more
and more people are trying to buy real
estate the prices are extremely quickly
increasing right yeah we know this so
Taylor Swift tickets yeah right I don't
know how much Farmland there is in
America it's a lot but at a certain
point the costs are going to increase
very very high and BlackRock if they're
not earning a return on their I'm not
I'm not a fan of BlackRock by the way
I'm not saying this is something we
should be like applauding I'm just
saying there are mechanisms already in
place that the idea that BlackRock can
buy America I don't even know how much
the cost of America would be it just
would be insane and I want to point out
too your concerns about BlackRock are
based on the fact that they get free
money from the government yeah exactly
it's not the government I mean it's the
bank so you want more government to deal
with the problem of government no the
government it's not the government it's
the Federal Reserve and the bank for
international settlements that are
supplying the funds to Blackrock it's
not the American government we are in
favor of treating the members of the
Federal Reserve as war criminals I think
I can speak for Luke in this is that
fair to say yes okay
private company but no no more criminals
Federal service is a private company are
you so I I I I am I am I I'm not saying
they're not war criminals I'm just
saying it's a private company they're
not a private company at all and they
should be treated like war criminals are
you suggesting they're a government
agency I'm not suggesting it I'm saying
it no the Federal Reserve is a private
it's a quasi private exactly
organization but it was invented by JD
Rockefeller John Rockefeller Paul
Warburg in 1913. this is the nightmare
scenario of when you have this kind of
corporate government intertwining where
you have this almost like a Frankenstein
creature that's half one foot half the
other and no accountability no liability
and that is exactly what anarchists like
me and Luke and anarchists of all colors
of the Black Flag are opposed to because
this is what Marx referred to as
capitalism fascism now I agree that
fascism is the other end of the spectrum
whereas corporatism is equally as
dangerous corporatism is fascism it's
just fascism with the better brand name
fascism is going to bring government
into it corporatism could be like
John Rockefeller owns every road and now
if John Rockefeller doesn't like you he
can't drive okay that's bad how is he
gonna afford do you know how much every
road would cost like even Elon Musk with
45 billion dollars that can buy you
maybe the roads in like one city yeah
but they know the bankers that print the
money and they can but again that's the
federal that's the Federal Reserve it's
not American government that's different
it's a private company the American
Reserve has given their power to it's
total Co-op of our government yes that
is corporatism they're using government
in to do this the government is the Fall
Guy the American Republic is legit
what is their America a republic is the
government it's supposed to smash up
Monopoly supposed to is a blue pilled
word supposed to doesn't exist anymore
we have you know Anti-Trust laws to
break up like Rockefeller standard oil
at the end of the year we have antitrust
laws so monopolies will play ball by
whoever's in power even Teddy Roosevelt
and Wilson who were the first two
Progressive presidents both explicitly
said there are good trusts and bad
trusts meaning the monopolies that do
what we want and not police that don't
do what they want this is exactly a
mechanism just like Facebook and
Google's other things Biden will call
you up because he's got these antitrust
laws behind him or whatever other laws
at his dispose and be like you know what
we'd really like it if you are censoring
this misinformation it's dangerous to
our democracy and they're like oh of
course we're doing it privately but it's
not privately because it's a complete
collusion between the state and the free
market extensively free markets do you
think that if if Government were totally
removed and it was just Market that it
would work out that everybody would be
happier and and well healthier and not
everyone certainly the politicians are
they're gonna it's gonna be really hard
for them when consequences will never be
the same I feel like Corporation
tendency to profit over human goodness
is like you can only prosperous people
like slaves you can only slavery is not
profitable it's expensive number one and
besides it's immoral would you be buying
candy bars from a company that's built
on slave labor
uh well the sneakers I got this thing
it's probably built in a Chinese lab
yeah I think I think everything in here
might be like not into everything but a
lot of it's this table is actually
American made locally the cameras are
foreign made by people in horrible
conditions well that's a problem it is I
agree that's why we make governments to
stop that in my opinion the benevolence
of government is that it can protect us
but in fact over the past couple of
decades the government has been
colluding with foreign corporations to
sell all of our jobs overseas to benefit
China
it's what Nixon did with the with
Rockefeller and Henry Kissinger it was
an open policy the open China policy
that they implemented so you got to
understand like Ian at the end of the
day all roads lead to of course the
government abusing its power because
they don't need to provide a service
based on any kind of reputation or any
kind of consequences we're gonna go to
super chats oh sorry to cut you guys off
uh if you haven't already we just smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com I
have gotten word from the crew here that
there is going to be a behind the scenes
breakdown of what happened with yay and
the crew when they came because we
filmed their Journey here there's
conversation stuff that happens so we
are going to have some kind of members
only uh uh footage of how everything
went down and uh it'll be interesting
but we're gonna have a members only show
up for you guys tonight around 11 pm is
when we upload it so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really want to support
us all right we got Set Me Free who says
Balenciaga is for abusers only if you
rock it we know know how you get down
what's wrong with you
there you go yeah I was hoping to talk
to yay about that uh yesterday because
he did a lot of work with Balenciaga and
um you know a lot of people are being
questioned about it rightfully so and I
think you know I wonder what he knows
from inside of the industry if if it's
even you know Sinister from there but
sadly that didn't happen yeah Raymond g
Stanley Green says Tim dude everywhere I
look Tim pool this Temple that I can't
stand all of the weak afbs out there we
have a nation to say we have a movement
to continue there's no time for childish
BS Games
I'm kind of with that man I think
forgiveness is the fever of the day so I
want to point some goodness I want
Vengeance are you kidding for what they
did for two years maybe do both yeah we
could forgive about this full
forgiveness then forgiveness I think
Justice I'm I I try to be careful with
the idea of Vengeance because but it's
so fun I agree it feels good yeah it
does but um and if it feels good you
should do it especially if children are
involved no that was the lesson of the
day no no you know that song I mean it
is episode 666. you know that song that
makes you happy then why the hell is it
so bad yeah I was I was heard that and
thought about like just drug abuse and I
was just like what is wrong with this
person singing this like what is she
saying that's true but I I know the song
isn't about drug abuse but you know I
just kind of was like there's a lot of
things that make you happy yeah very
very bad for you what were you just
saying before you got before Michael
derailed because you're about to say a
point that I wanted Michael to hear
which I don't remember what was the
Super chat about about average oh yeah I
was gonna say that um
after the car right now is trial
derailed you know the the conversation
was like oh do we try and book Kyle
Rittenhouse and I was just like no if
they reach out to us of course he just
he just followed me last night on
Twitter there you go but what I don't
like doing is being like let's be the
first to get the big person and then
I I just gotta say
I am not happy with how things went down
yesterday
and I wake up in the morning and it's
like I'm trending I hate trending I have
no you know I've never trended and it
really drives me crazy because like all
my friends have trended I'm such a loser
I know I know same everybody right now
if they if everybody right now tweeted
Michael malice just right now you'd be
trending I'm a very very very little man
in every in every sense of the word but
um we we end up doing this booking
because it was like hey we could have
this big story on the show and it and it
implodes on us and I'm like
I'd rather just have people in that we
find are interesting and talk about the
news I didn't think it imploded on you
at all to be honest we I I'll put it
this way our plan was not to have them
storm out you know what I mean I I
thought we were going to talk about news
and we just happened to have the people
who are in the news here and it turned
into
I I I feel like Yay planned it I really
do because when we were talking
beforehand he was calm the points I made
during the show were similar points I
had just made 20 minutes before you
didn't raise your voice you didn't
interrupt him and then he and I feel
like people it's funny because people
don't know what happened before the show
so there's all these comments about what
I did wrong and everything and I'm like
the pre-show you know they're like you
shouldn't have brought up that article
about Pence and I'm like I brought it up
an hour before the show started they
were there's a big screen right there
that everyone can see and it was right
there yay looked at it read it and then
said would it Pence like betray Trump is
that what happened and then Flint I
started talking about what what January
6 in Pence but bringing up Pence was
Jermaine Pence was condemning the dinner
so ask him his opinion about it what you
weren't saying Pence is right get out of
my house no I said this is the news
there's a dinner that happened tell us
and he immediately went into the subject
and it was very very different to
everything that happened before and it
is can you describe how his affect
changed because when watching him
sitting here he really seemed like he
had a huge chip on his shoulder before
the show he was sitting here texting on
his phone minding his business he was he
was uh uh he looked up he was calmly
talking to Milo he was smiling they
asked what he asked questions there was
something came up about Sin our all sins
created equal and Milo said certainly
some sins are worse than others like no
one's going to claim you know and then
he makes a few comparisons and then yay
smiles and he says something of like you
know all sin and then he looked at the
article he makes a comment it was very
very calm and we were chill and we were
chilling yeah he was talking about doing
the show every every week he was like we
got to do this more we got we should do
this once a week and I'm like that could
be Hollywood talk though sure but he he
brought up something about how I can't
remember exactly what he's saying but it
was about Jewish people I I said
something did he say Jewish people to
say the Jews he said Jewish people okay
so that's interesting okay yeah yeah I
mean isn't that what that's what I
thought he kept saying but whatever he
he said he said you know Jewish people
are something very calm look laid back
smiling and I made a point about Bezos
Elon I mean these are wealthy people and
he goes yeah but come on Elon works for
the Jews right and then he looks at Milo
and he says didn't they have him do that
thing or whatever that ceremony or
something very common even when I pushed
back and said he's on Twitter he's
unbanning people yay was chill totally
calm camera goes on he starts going off
I gotta talk about this and donut trip
because I'll walk out on your show I
tell you very very different that's why
if you look I'm like confused look at my
face when he walks out I'm like is he
walking out loud because you were just I
don't know you said I don't agree and
he's like Deuces it's like you didn't
yell at him yeah but anyway anyway I
don't want to keep rehashing this I just
wanted to bring up the point that
I I'm I'm wary of doing shows like that
because there are people who are like I
want to get press oh yeah yeah yeah and
so I was concerned and I said I was like
maybe him walking out made the story
very big
like I want to do a show where we talk
about ideas and like we don't do drama
we don't like drama and now like before
the show started today we were talking
about what's the big story to talk about
and it's like you know Ian you are like
we're the news and I'm like that's you
know you're right you're not wrong I'm
like that kind of sucks yeah I want to
talk about what Trump's doing I want to
know what his plans I don't know how
that affects us and here we are in this
in in sort of a I shouldn't say where
the center yays of the center but we're
on the edge of it and it's our fault
because we want to do a show it turned
into a PR spectacle instead of a
conversation about what was going on I
think it's the Natural Evolution of the
show as well that it's just going to
keep getting bigger and bigger and it'll
become more and more of the focus of the
human consciousness stuff the
conversations like this I think you're
right like Rogan you know Joe said I
just want to hang out with my friends
and talk and then all of a sudden his
shows became the news yeah and that that
worries and well I'm gonna play Devil's
Advocate because it is 666. I'd rather
that be the news than whatever is going
on on Anderson Cooper or Sean Hannity
that night I think it's much more more
honest let's let's we'll keep bringing
super chats because I want to leave you
guys hanging deprived dolphin says
project Veritas has a new video on
federal sponsored human trafficking I
saw a bit of it did you guys see some of
this report like a whistleblower from
the government talking about this stuff
I gotta I gotta watch the whole thing I
just had James on my show he did a great
job it was a lot of fun okay dude yeah
excellent uh I'm I I'm excited they got
unbanned did James personally get
unbanned yes I believe so I'm 90 sure
that was so egregious it's crazy and and
the creepy cultists who cheer that on
good news though good news though is
that episode out yet yeah on your
welcome on my on yes and you are welcome
all right bub sevy says Tim Destiny
thinks Fuentes would run circles around
you in a debate hilarious you should
have Rosalind KD on the no jumper Pod
episode today all think your anti
anti-semitic apparently oh because they
didn't watch the hour of me ranting
against anti-Semitism that resulted in
people saying we get it to him shut up
literally how dude yeah like we we were
complaining about all of that stuff but
they're not real people and I'll tell
you this we're not real people and
you're not an anti-semite we all you all
heard him you all heard him the the
trolls online are are drama baiters
thank you
this guy this guy Michael melison Master
drama baiters uh let me tell you
um you see my videos
Destiny thinks Fuentes would run circles
around me in a debate oh yeah they
probably would I don't debate people uh
I I I don't he's he prepares for this is
all he does I don't think I'm this I'm
the smartest person who can I I have
convictions I have beliefs sometimes the
wrong Sheamus I was there's a really
important point I was arguing with
Sheamus on a show boy was it
embarrassing I kept saying abortion
means this you're wrong no you're wrong
and then like a few days later after
reading it I was like oh boy I was wrong
that's embarrassing and then I came out
and I was like Shameless you're right I
was just wrong about NPR today dude it's
so valuable maybe find out everybody I
think everybody's wrong at some point in
their life when you realize it that is
so valuable for your mind here's my
point
I love Ian so much someone who uh like
someone who is confident
will win a debate knowing nothing over a
scientist with a PhD in that field if
you are a talker and you can speak you
can make it sound like there's this
great debate which I couldn't sit
through because I was bored with Bill
Nye the Science Guy against a
creationist and the creationist knew
what Bill Nye was going to say whereas
bill and I thought the guy was just
going to be like God put Noah blah blah
idiocy and the creation is just handing
like knocking him out and build a lot as
nice like what do I do yep
well Bill nye's not really a Science Guy
correct you know that's funny he's an
engineer but uh there are people who are
really good at debate and you don't need
to know facts to be good at debate but
it does help
um and those people tend to become
lawyers yeah debate tactics I'm looking
at them there's things like argument
that's a debate tactic there's is awe is
that a debate tactic where you can
actually put your opponent in awe and
then they back down yeah uh Gish Gallup
is I think is the best example yes it's
where you throw out a whole bunch of
points all at once so they can't answer
any of them or is it but if they only
answer one it's going to take 15 minutes
that means the others on the table yeah
yep yep so that's that's you know that's
why I'm like I like having discussions
you know I'll invite people and we'll
have a talk and if I disagree I will say
what I disagree on and if I'm wrong we
had um Matt Bender here and I mixed up a
city and I was very confident arrogant
about it you're wrong yeah and I pulled
up and went whoops in the wrong City you
got me and then they clipped the video
and they're like aha Tim's wrong I'm
like yeah I know I don't think people
appreciate at home how often if you're
doing this live and the conversations
Dynamic you're going to even just have
brain farts and to speak here's a good
one Mr P says episode 666 on the 333rd
day of 2022 how about that whoa
okay does that mean something mechanical
simulation baby
for Ian it does yeah I got I got chills
right now and I'm not lying Goosebumps
and it's currently 9 45 p.m I don't
understand that four plus five equals
nine oh yeah three six nine the sacred
numbers the universal numbers and it's
666 on episode on day uh on the three
third three Thirty third day at the
ninth hour what's what's 90 cut in half
45 9 4.5 I agree 946 now let's dismember
Ian the numbers have spoke to Colt the
entire time yeah man
all right let's see we got here anything
happened to Lydia attack Fuji says I
wasn't very interested in interested in
Mouse's opinions but then I saw his
underwear ads in Times Square and I
decided I would fight the state then I
saw a cat noticed I had Twitter
notifications and now lost
sheathunderwear.com promo code malice
was it in Times Square no oh okay oh oh
he's oh he's talking about your ad yeah
oh okay he said underwear as in Times
Square but it's just you yeah should we
put you up in your underwear in Times
Square I mean maybe when I get my [ __ ]
gutters back uh I I think you're gonna
be back up in Times Square again too oh
awesome we're doing New Year's Eve oh
heck yeah you told me that yeah yeah the
whole Tower yeah that was very
depressing going back to New York I was
very very upset when were you there uh
just in August to see the billboard that
you guys put out it really upset me it
was a lot what was the worst hitting the
billboard
if you think I'm ugly now look at me
when I'm this tall
um no it was that I'd been gone for a
year this is the city I lived my entire
life and that you would think there'd
been a year to heal and it remained
exactly the same if anything that had
changed had changed for the worse to
have like 30 of the storefronts not be
occupied yeah and within 10 minutes or
15 let's say I saw someone peeing on a
van in the street not on the sidewalk
and people are like that's always been
New York I've lived in New York all my
life that's not been a common occurrence
it was just a corporate change I was
just back a couple days ago too it's
horrible yeah I hate it I'm so saddened
by it the curly Afro says I have waited
so long to see Michael malice return on
timcast just to say you sir are a
national treasure that must be protected
oh that is so nice thank you
thank you
all right how much did you pay him to
say that
he paid a couple bucks 50 shekels vacant
stare says I prefer malice's razor never
a tribute to malice that which can be
explained by Hanlon
I like that as a brilliant that was
really smart left hands are smart
okay okay
um keto Thor says Ian looking mighty
cozy tonight yo it's cold in here yeah
the the heaters stopped working so like
the AC gave out and then we got the AC
effect but we didn't realize the heat
wasn't working so now it's cold out now
that heat's not working yeah so I'm like
I was texting the show like yo these are
some first real problem gay was cold too
he was wearing that big coat he was like
why it's so cold in here I'm like bro I
don't know you know why because we
control the weather
specifically yeah like why I walked out
my thing it was just cold it's cold in
here at this I'm out
okay what do we got here you know where
it's not called Israel
oh yeah what's the temperature like
there perfect code there it's always
perfect is it like 70 degrees it's the
desert It's gotta be super hot one day I
want to take the Balfour Declaration the
creation of Israel I want to have a long
conversation about it in a safe place in
a place where we can talk about it
online with people I think that that
place does not exist but then we need to
create a safe place to discuss that on
the internet I don't know about that
yeah Ian wants a safe space
hey look maybe the government can build
him one yeah on the road
all right AI says I've always said if
the Dems were serious about
investigating Trump they would have a
special committee on Epstein what do
they do investigate a fake dossier and a
bunch of Maga nobodies priorities
if they were serious about Trump then it
would have been Epstein first but
they're not serious about any of it no
they're just going after political
opponents
all right one pissed off hippie says the
machine elf Michael malice please
unblock me on Twitter I won't call you a
lawn gnome or share the meme please end
my struggles what's his username I'll do
it right now one pissed off hippie he's
cool is this a number one or the word
one the number word one is that his
Twitter handle yeah one pissed off
hippie number one pissed off no no dude
I'm gonna make sure it's the number one
with his username and then I'll unblock
him yeah I'm gonna go for this and make
sure it happens tonight dude thanks for
super chatting that
all right
Eraserhead says if YouTube and other
sites lose the ability to do search
doesn't the internet just revert back to
where everyone uses YouTube to host
their videos and those videos get
embedded in the personal websites of
creators and Brands uh or YouTube is a
reverse chronological feed where people
see the videos that were recently posted
which will look at Instagram almost
exactly yeah because they can't
recommend they can just when someone
posts it it'll appear if someone chooses
to see it uh I think that would be a
good thing yeah that actually would make
a lot of sense a lot of big prominent
people would disappear I I guess
according to Darren Beatty Lex Friedman
would be gone really why because he he's
made the argument that YouTube's
algorithm is just forcing Friedman on
everybody in all fairness I mean you not
you can't be surprised that one robot's
gonna recommend another robot yeah
but uh it is it is an interesting point
though you go on YouTube and you look at
these things and it's like instantly
recommends Lex Friedman podcast yeah is
Lex Friedman is awesome in person as he
is on TV
um
I absolutely Lex and I are next door
neighbors right and there may have been
times when I've never I feel bad saying
this but I'll say it anyway my Nest my
video camera looks at his house so
sometimes when I'm bored I keep I'm like
when is Lex leave it coming up that's
weird
fighting and there was this one time
where there was like this chair in the
garbage and I was like oh I wonder when
he threw this chair out and then I
looked and he actually went the garbage
can and made it stick out more and I
have to ask him about this but you know
what you should you guys should do a
funny bit where like you're watching his
door and then he walks out and then he
just like he walks out the door and it
stops and slowly looks no no no no no
Tim this is the joke and I told the
celex uh I hear when the garage opens
because my office is right there he had
a guest leaving his podcast and he's
saying goodbye them and I'm like I gotta
get like a clan Clan uniform here so
that like when I hear him saying goodbye
to guests I like open the door I'm like
hey Lex how's it going like the wacky
sitcom neighbor and he has to explain oh
no it's just Michael he's just like that
so if someone wants to send me a clan
uniform to add to the seven I already
have yeah that would be really great no
but Lex is really one of he has for
someone who is made of uh um string and
wires he has like the biggest heart
maybe if anyone I know I think they like
bring you fruit baskets no he's very
kind of keeps himself and I I really
don't want to be like always knocking
his door I want to respect his face I
don't like that kind of thing but he
really takes a lot of stuff to he's very
passionate about things so this this him
online is a lot like what he is in real
life he's he maybe he's like a lot
funnier in person like a lot more joking
maybe it's because of me but he really
cares a lot about people something I I
can't relate to at all bro code he says
Tim not that I'm counting or anything
but you're oh and two with rap artists
on your podcast Fair Point that's true
have we had any other rappers
Tom McDonald please McDonald's give us
one Victory I could bring some more if
you want oh yeah Luke was the one Luke
was the one who wanted Kanye on the show
hey one pissed off hippie tweet at me
really quick so I can see your account
and the other guy who uh you know
ready to rumble says Tim your chat has
become toxic hater vomit you know people
are allowed to say things even if they
don't like me so it's like the cop you
know what do you do if people show up
and they get in the chat and they start
saying that they don't they don't they
don't like the show or I'm bad or
whatever I'm like okay but you're not
really Dynamic I mean it goes very very
fast yeah yeah well we try to read all
the chats we have to put it on slow mode
oh okay and subscribers okay subscriber
only and so all the people who hate me
are subscribing and they want to say
they don't like me and they're allowed
to say they don't like me of course so
you know cash that check during occupy I
was live streaming
um and it was like all these leftists
like liberal people who are watching of
course and then a bunch of conservatives
came in and started smack talking and
everything
the viewers that were like more left we
like 2 000 viewers at the time on my
phone they were like Tim you got to ban
these people you got to ban them and
then I just said why would I ban them
they're allowed to talk they're allowed
they're allowed to dislike me they they
don't have to agree with Occupy Wall
Street they want to know what's going on
too and then also they're like oh this
team guy's pretty cool and they started
like saying like oh okay we're gonna
keep trolling but we appreciate that
you're letting us and I'm like just
don't spam guys at the end of the day
you got to appreciate the trolls okay I
got a couple no one's ever called you
cool I don't believe this story for a
second I bet you could it's not Tim cool
no not yet but there are other words
that rhyme with cool
that's true
taste glazed that's right so they've
called me those things too
I I've called you those things on this
show there's a lot because he calls me
Pim tool off the air
you know
do you know I think the funniest name
for Trump was and it took them four
years to think of this Toronto dump I'm
like that's actually a good one yeah
that's a good one I sent you his uh
Twitter by the way I think it's one I'll
just reply to yours I just message it
yeah perfect
Jack Ryan says Milo declared on on your
November 9th show you cannot give people
the first and second amendment unless
they're Christian you just can't those
are rights that uh that I a non-believer
fought for and better men have died in
war to protect for All American citizens
he said non-believer like you repeat
that
I don't remember that yeah I I I'm
pretty sure he said something like you
said you can't call a non-believer
Christian no he said you cannot give
people the first and second amendment
unless they're Christians you just can't
it was it was a quote
um or I think it's from him he said
those are rights that I
oh okay I think Jack Ryan is saying that
oh okay I'm sorry I'm sorry Milo said
you cannot give people the first second
amendment unless they're Christian you
can't then Jack Ryan is saying those are
rights that I a non-believer fought for
and better men have died for to protect
for All American citizens yeah I think a
lot of Christian beliefs are in our
system our agnostic system so you can
you can still run I don't know if you
need to be a Christian I I think
literally over 90 of Christians who
believe in the second 95 would agree
that everyone has the right to protect
themselves Michael what yeah it's
episode 666 yeah on the 333rd day of the
year yeah which equals 999. yeah and I
read it at 9 45 and half of 9 is 4.5 and
they were currently 54 000 viewers which
equals nine wow hermanus that proves it
Herman Cain is spinning in his grave
so sick of Lex being shoved down my
throat Lex has the most boring vanilla
opinions on everything that he does get
recommended everywhere fine that's the
point that's the point that we're making
is that like the recommend like YouTube
he he probably has more recommendations
than any other podcast I I'm gonna I'm
sorry I never thought I I I if I I I'm
not saying I'm not saying anything bad
about it I didn't think I'd well that
person is it I'm gonna I'm happy to
defend Lex I don't think he has boring
vanilla pins and everything I think his
big principle and what he's doing well
is bushing to do is for people to be
kinder to one another to listen to each
other one another and to be less
antagonistic and more uh cooperative and
I think that's a great message that I
don't entirely agree with all right
Edward says Ian rolled a 20 and Malice
deflected Ian is Right government by the
community depends on the community dude
lives in a fantasy and it's hilarious
what
well
yeah thank you uh Community Governor I
well the like there's going to be a form
of governance no matter what correct I'm
not disagreeing with that yeah Troy
rubert doesn't forget he has neither he
didn't disagree with that either right
there's a scope and scale of the current
government that's the big problem Troy
Robert says don't forget he has
synesthesia and uh he sees sound do you
Ian Kanye I think I do too sometimes
when I when I listen to music and play
music I visualize it the note if the
note goes up I visualize it on a line
graph and I can see it and sometimes
it'll become a three-dimensional graph
okay
that's interesting is it I do as well
fun fact I'll explain it later though
red Vista says just a point for the
discoverability of your channel the way
I discovered this channel is I looked up
Joe Rogan drama when he was being
canceled and just filtered search by Max
views and got here wow interesting
people complain often that you'll search
for my name and it's something about
haters like people are trying to find
this show and they find nothing but
people hating on me wow and this has
happened to other people I'm not going
to drag into the conversation but other
prominent people who are not
establishment aligned are like if you
get the establishment left channels
ragging on you instead of the people
actually trying to find the show wow
yeah I do think that algorithmically if
I type in someone's name it should take
me to their Channel first of course and
then that's a no-brainer yeah yep all
right track media only says someone
needs to tell malice that some people
still buy iPhones so yes people will buy
products made by slave labor I think
that point was made right you were like
oh well thank you for informing me that
people still buy iPhones thank you for
this new information I'm not gonna buy
and I I'm not going to buy Apple yeah
not anytime soon I'm Federal but you
won't be able to well to be fair I want
to make sure I clarify we have Apple
devices here because we're building an
app and we're we've started building an
IOS app I'm not a big fan of Apple but I
recognize people use it I would love to
see X phone from Elon or something but
uh I prefer Android I use Android I got
Android here it is what it is
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
this with your friends become a member
at timcast.com one of the members only
show coming up for you at 11 PM over at
timcast.com where you can click the join
us button sign up and support our work
you can follow the show at timcastirl
follow us on Instagram you can follow me
personally at 10 test basically
everywhere I post stupid things on
Twitter if you want to see them Michael
do you want to shout anything out uh you
could follow me at twitter.com Michael
malice there's a few hundred copies left
signed hardcovers and once they're gone
they're gone that's the top tweet on
twitter.com Michael malice and you're
welcome uh is going to be great for the
rest of the year and I'll be back very
soon to launch the white pill a tale of
Good and Evil which is a book I've been
working on for two years We'll order
pizza and wings when you when we do it
okay
thanks for coming and helping me deal
with the statist and collectivists here
I I appreciate that you're all a bunch
of socialists wait can I tell that story
quickly when mises ludov gun mises with
the mount Palin society and Milton
Friedman and all of them were discussing
how in a free Society you could still
have a um some kind of progressive
income tax and lubricant means stood up
and said you're all a bunch of
socialists and stormed out of the room a
bunch of socialists my YouTube channel
is uh youtube.com forward slash we are
change I just did a video about Elon
China check it out it's up there right
now and if you're a member of
lukeansensor.com I did a video about all
the behind the scenes things that were
happening here check it out
lucensored.com see you there right after
this broadcast thank you again so much
for having me this fall median
crossland.net all my social media Ian
Crossland YouTube Facebook Twitter mines
the list goes on Michael great to see
you again brother uh where when people
watch your welcome what time of day what
day I drop it Wednesdays at like in the
evening like usually around seven all
right thanks for coming man what's
happening Serge and I'm still search
come with the high energy coming through
love you guys thanks for checking out
all right everybody yesterday we will
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out Nick